mask people wear masks because CDC has
said quote simple cloth coverings slow
the spread of the virus and help people
who may have the virus and do not know
it from transmitting it to others
unfortunately this simple life-saving
practice has become part of the
political debate that says this if
you're for Trump you don't wear a mask
him you're against Trump you do that's
why I've suggested that the president
occasionally wear a mask even though in
most cases it's not necessary for him to
do so
the president has plenty of admirers
they would follow his lead it would help
end this political bait debate the
stakes are too high for this political
debate about pro Trump
anti Trump masks to continue around here
senators and staff wear masks because we
don't want to make each other sick for
example I was exposed to Cova 19 by a
pre-symptomatic staff member on my way
to Dulles Airport and as a result had to
self quarantine for two weeks the Senate
physician told me that one reason I
didn't become infected was because the
staff member was wearing a mask and that
and the physicians were greatly reduced
the chances of an exposure it's also a
pretty good way to make a statement I
like to wear my plaid mask doctor Falchi
uses his mask to demonstrate his loyalty
to the Washington Nationals senator
Kaine is either a cowboy or abandoned
I'm never sure which if you want college
football to return this fall here is
what coach Phillip Fulmer our athletic
director at the University of Tennessee
says if you really really want to see
some football this fall wear a mask that
it might have more influence than
anybody else in Tennessee the United
States is in the midst of a very
concerning rise in kovat 19 cases and
hospitalizations in many states the
experts in front of us have told us that
washing our hands staying apart and
wearing a mask are three of the most
important ways to contain the disease
and
the spread of the virus I'm grateful to
the Rules Committee the sergeant-at-arms
the press gallery the architect of the
Capitol the Capitol Capitol Police our
committee staff both Democratic and
Republican Chun shik and Evan Griffiths
and all for their hard work to keep us
safe now senator Murray and I will each
have an opening statement and then we
will turn to our witnesses who we thank
for being with us today each will have
five minutes we'd ask you to summarize
your your testimony in five minutes and
then the Senators will have a chance to
ask five minute round of questions we
have full participation today it looks
like should be an interesting morning
among the casualties of this dangerous
and very sneaky kovat 19 virus are the
75 million students who were sent home
from school and college and March and to
the casualties the teachers who weren't
prepared to teach remotely and the
working parents who suddenly had
children at home and who weren't
prepared to home-school had the lost
sports seasons and the
once-in-a-lifetime graduation
opportunities then they were
unprecedented dilemmas for
administrators in inadequate school
budgets being sent home from school
doesn't rank where the sickness and the
death that the virus has caused the
United States says over 2.5 million
cases of the virus and over 125,000
deaths according to Johns Hopkins
while states and communities continue to
take action to keep people safe nothing
though was more disruptive to American
life and nothing would head it back
toward normalcy more rapidly then for
those hundred and thirty five thousand
public and private schools and six
thousand colleges to reopen this fall
earlier this month
this committee heard from college
presidents and school leaders about
their plans for safely reopening this
fall this hearing is an opportunity for
an update and to hear from the nation's
top health experts on how headmasters
principals superintendents Chancellor's
and college presidents can open their
schools safely just a few weeks from now
this committee last heard from today's
four Witnesses on May the 12th when
three of the four were quarantined and
most of
senators were participating virtually
that was one of the first virtual Senate
hearings in history and surely the best
watched every Network carried the two
and a half hours of statements and
questions and answers from senators the
question before the country today is not
whether to go back to school or college
or childcare or work but how to do it
safely
even though Cova 19 is not in general
hurt young children and college-age
students nearly as much as older and
more vulnerable Americans there is some
health risk but in my view the greater
risk is not going back to school
guidance for reopening schools from the
American Academy of pediatricians tell
school administrators the following our
Academy strongly believes that all
policy considerations for the coming
school year
should start with a goal of having
students physically present in school
the Academy continues the importance of
in-person learning is well documented
there is already evidence of negative
impacts on children because of school
closures in the spring of 2020 lengthy
time away from school and associated
interruption of supportive services
often results in social isolation making
it difficult for schools to identify and
address important learning deficits as
well as child and adolescent physical or
sexual abuse substance use depression
and suicidal ideation
this in turn places children and
adolescents at considerable risk of
morbidity and in some cases mortality
beyond the educational impact and social
impact of school closures there's been
substantial impact on food security and
physical activity for children and
families
that's the American Academy of
pediatricians dr. Lloyd Fisher that the
incoming president of the Massachusetts
chapter of that Academy of pediatricians
told reporters while for most children
Cova 19 has not had the devastating and
life-threatening physical health defects
facts that have occurred in adults the
negative impact on their education
mental health and social development has
been substantial unquote nothing can
take the place of the daily face-to-face
interaction our children experienced
when attending school in person dr.
Fischer said many American colleges
overall considered the best in the world
will be permanently damaged or even
closed if they remain in brown
university presidents Christina Paxson's
words ghost towns mitch Daniels the
president of Purdue wrote in a
Washington Post op-ed quote failure to
take on the job of reopening would not
only be anti scientific but also an
unacceptable breach of duty so today in
addition to hearing more about the
concerning rise in cases and
hospitalizations in some states I'd like
to ask our witnesses and their
statements and when sirs two questions
to put yourselves in the place of one of
America's approximately 14,000
superintendents of school districts or
the principal or headmaster of one of a
hundred and thirty-five thousand schools
or as president or Chancellor of one of
six thousand colleges and help them
answer the question of how to reopen
schools and colleges safely so dr.
Falchi I hope that in your opening
statement our answers to questions
you'll suggest steps a superintendent
might take to open schools safely and
not only how to keep children safe but
to keep safe the adults teachers parents
grandparents with whom they come in
contact dr. Hahn will there be
treatments or medicines this fall that
will help speed the recovery from Kovan
19 or reduce the possibility of death I
believe the fear of going back to school
are going anywhere these days is in
large part because of the fear of severe
illness or even death if that risk can
be lessened by new treatments it should
increase confidence in going back to
school I'd also like to commend dr. Hahn
and the work the FDA did to get tests on
the market quickly as possible to help
understand the spread of the virus since
then
FDA has worked out which tests have not
worked as well as they should and taken
steps to remove them from the market
that's what's supposed to happen in the
urgency of a pandemic ed Bulger wha and
our last hearing you said you expected
there to be 40 to 50 million diagnostic
tests available each month by September
is that still true and exactly how does
the school district go about making sure
it gets those tests and who pays for
them what are the prospects from the
shark tank at the National Institutes of
Health that there will be new reliable
and inexpensive tests so we can have
even more widespread testing and dr.
Redfield you're continuing to work on
updated guidelines about going back to
school and college safely and our CDC
employees going to be available in our
state's to help work with school
districts to develop their plans and
what advice do you have about the
arrival of the flu season this fall at
the same time as kovat 19 this is a lot
to discuss but there will be time during
the next two and a half hours to answer
most of those questions
let me quickly highlight three areas
that have come up in our four earlier
hearings this month that I think need
clarification first on contact tracing
the no doubt contact tracing is
crucially important it identifies the
people who might have been exposed so
that people who don't so that they don't
in turn expose someone else according to
an NPR report on June 18 states have
already hired at least 37,000 contact
tracers state officials and John Hopkins
center for health security issue issued
a report estimating the need for as many
as 100,000 contact tracers several
reports suggested Congress appropriates
money to pay for those tracers the
reality is Congress already has on April
24th Congress appropriated 11 billion
which has been sent to States and tribes
for the expenses of testing that
legislation explain
we said the money could be used for
contact tracing this is in addition to
755 million from the first emergency
appropriations legislation on March 6
that could be used for contact tracing
and that's in addition to the March 27
legislation in which Congress
appropriated 150 billion dollars I mean
one point five billion in the cares Act
for States territories and tribes to use
for covert preparedness and response the
Carrey's act also included the one
hundred fifty billion dollars to States
but a significant amount of that 150
billion dollars has not been spent even
though it is all designated for expenses
related to covent 19 which include
contact tracing for example Tennessee's
governor has told me he's reserving as
much as a billion of that so that he can
determine what flexibility he has in
spending the money Washington state has
not spent as much as 1.2 billion
Missouri State Treasurer says they've
not spent about a billion according to
the report by state health officials in
Johns Hopkins an average salary for a
contact tracer would be a little more
than $35,000 this adds up to about 3.5
billion for a hundred thousand contact
tracers so the point is Congress has
already sent to States plenty of money
to hire all the contact tracers that are
needed
second who pays for the testing in the
cares Act Congress voted to make all
Cova 19 tests available to patients at
no cost
this meant insurers would cover
diagnostic tests which detect whether a
person is currently infected with the
virus and also antibody tests which
indicate whether a person has had kovat
19 in the past and now may have some
protection in the future guidance from
the Labor Department Treasury Department
and Centers for Medicare and Medicaid
Services said last week that insurers
are only required to pay for tests
without patient cost-sharing in
a doctor orders it I agree with that but
given that the CDC specifically
recommends doctor's orders tests in two
situations when a person has signs or
symptoms of Cova 19 or recently had
contact with someone known or suspected
to have a Kovan 19 who pays for the
testing at other times I believe
Congress will need to take action to
further clarify who pays for the testing
at other times for example a school may
want to do random testing perhaps it
should make an arrangement with the
state to pay for that or perhaps
Congress needs to provide more money to
pay for that if an automaker wants to
test all of its employees at the plan
every two weeks perhaps the automaker
should pay for that or perhaps the state
would want to pay for that that needs to
be clarified
finally flu shots CDC has said more
people need to get flu shots this fall
so health care workers can better
distinguish between Cova 19 and the flu
Sidi says a priority is for all children
over the age of six months to be
vaccinated for the flu so they don't
become sick and pass it to more
vulnerable populations who can have more
severe consequences On January 24th
Senator Murray and I hosted our first
bipartisan briefing on coronavirus at a
time when there were only four cases in
the United States since then this is
committee has had four more briefings
today is our eighth hearing on
coronavirus and us preparedness last
week's hearing was about steps to take
this year while our eye is on the ball
to better prepare for the next pandemic
I've issued a white paper outlining five
recommendations for Congress to prepare
Americans for the next pandemic and that
paper has received more than 350
substantive comments that are available
to all members of the committee after
all senators have had a chance to ask
their questions I will conclude the
hearing by asking our witnesses if they
have two or three suggestions about
steps Congress should take this year to
deal with the next
pandemic most of which will also help
with this one
but this hearing is about what happens
now as administrators prepare to reopen
schools and colleges experts
underestimated this dangerous and sneaky
virus and there is still much we don't
know about it but we do know the basic
steps to take to reopen schools and
colleges in 2020 before there is a
vaccine and those are these social
distance where a mask
wash your hands test contact trace and
isolate those exposed or sick and
hopefully by the fall there will be
treatments to make the consequences of
the disease less severe I look forward
to hearing from our distinguished
witnesses how school leaders and college
presidents can safely reopen 135,000
schools and 6,000 colleges and also
learning the latest developments on
testing and treatments that we can
expect during the year 2020 before
vaccines arrive senator Murray thank you
very much mr. chairman today and of
course thank you our staff for setting
up the technology so we can hold this
hearing safely I want to get to the
point quickly and I'm gonna be blunt
about it the Cova 19 response in our
country is still disaster a hundred and
twenty-six thousand lives lost was once
considered an estimate on the high end
but the years just half way over and it
is now a grim reality we have lost more
Americans to Kovan 19 than we lose to
the flu each year than we lost to the
opioid crisis last year and more lives
than we've lost in every American war
except the Civil War and World War two
and despite what President Trump claims
this pandemic is not fading far from it
several states are seeing rapid
record-setting increases and the country
just saw its largest single-day
increased
today and while this public health
crisis rages across the country we've
seen a leadership crisis raging in the
White House as the president proves time
after time he cares less about how this
pandemic is impacting families and
communities and more about how it makes
him look just consider his appalling
continued failure on testing President
Trump said anyone that wants a test can
get a test they still can't
he said testing was overrated it is not
he said we prevailed on testing we have
not now he's saying we should be doing
fewer tests and testing makes us look
bad
well it clearly does not and we clearly
need to be doing more the most honest
thing he has said about testing is that
he doesn't take responsibility at all
and that is exactly the problem it's why
Congress actually took bipartisan action
in the last Cova 19 response bill to
require the Trump administration to
submit a comprehensive national testing
plan that's why I'm still pushing for
this administration to include more
details in that plan and take more steps
to ramp up testing because we are still
nowhere close to the testing and tracing
capacity we need to safely reopen our
country and ending support for federal
testing sites while sitting on billions
and testing fronts Congress provided is
not going to get us there the ongoing
struggle to get President Trump to take
testing seriously should be a stark
warning to Congress that when it comes
to vaccines we can't just leave this
administration to its own devices we
have to hold it accountable we know this
pandemic will not end until we have a
vaccine that is safe and effective that
can be widely produced and equitably
distributed and that is free and
accessible to everyone
which is why we need a comprehensive
National Vaccine plan from the Trump
administration as soon as possible
given
testing plan which Congress only
received after forcing the
administration's hand was too little too
late we need to take the opportunity we
have right now to get a vaccine plan
much earlier and avoid the missteps
we've seen with testing so I hope
Republicans will work with me in a
bipartisan way once again to require
this administration to put forward a
plan we need the Trump administration to
show us how they will ensure a vaccine
is safe and is effective I'm as eager as
anyone for a vaccine but this isn't just
about doing something fast it is about
doing it right that's why we need to
know the process for developing a
vaccine is rigorous it's inclusive it's
transparent and it is science driven but
in light of the high dr. Clark Kane
debacle and the removal of dr. bright
from Barda for questioning the
administration's efforts to promote that
unproven treatment we cannot take for
granted this process will be free of
political influence we have to demand
serious oversight in order to give the
public full confidence that a vaccine is
safe and effective the administration
needs to commit now to being fully
transparent about the standards a
vaccine will be expected to meet and
releasing the clinical trial data that
FDA uses to evaluate safety and
effectiveness we also need a plan
detailing how to produce and distribute
vaccines nationwide and make sure
everyone can actually give them we saw
with testing how avoidable bottlenecks
create damaging delays when the federal
government refuses to step in and lead
like it needs to do in a time of crisis
and unfortunately we saw how existing
health disparities are exacerbated
without a plan to overcome them as even
the incomplete data we currently have
shows black Latino and tribal
communities have significantly less
access to testing than white communities
this is an injustice that we must not
repeat when it comes to vaccines we also
need a plan to guarantee vaccines are
free so that cost is not a barrier for
patients and it's worth noting we still
need to activate Koba 19 treatment
available at no cost - and the plan must
address barriers like vaccine hesitancy
and misinformation especially one of the
woman one of the most prominent sources
of misinformation so far has been the
President of the United States
well the discovery of an eventual
vaccine may still be far off these are
issues we need the administration to
answer now so I hope Republicans will
work with me to require the
administration to submit a comprehensive
vaccine plan and address many of the
other urgent issues stemming from this
pandemic our businesses our workers
teachers students and families do not
have what they need to safely return to
work or school period our medical system
doctors nurses frontline workers
continue to face unimaginable risk
stress and fatigue they need Congress to
step up to help them continue to save
lives and families need us to continue
to ensure they have basic services and
can keep food on their tables the House
passed the heroes act 46 days ago to get
more relief to frontline workers to
families and businesses it is well past
time for leader McConnell and Senate
Republicans to sit down with fellow
Democrats and get to work there's no
question our country is still in crisis
and every day that Senate fails to take
action is a day we allow it to get worse
I also hope mr. chairman that we will be
able to have another hearing honest
prices soon with administration
officials whose testimony is long
overdue
secretary azar secretary DeVos and
Secretary Scalia Thank You mr. chairman
I look forward to our witnesses today
testimony and the questions that we have
for them Thank You senator Murray
we'd ask each witness now to summarize
his testimony in five minutes
pleased to welcome our witnesses each of
you are making significant contributions
to our government's response to Cova 19
helping us go safely back to school back
to work were grateful for your service
to our country our first witness is dr.
Anthony Falchi he's director of the
National Institute of Allergy and
Infectious Diseases
at the National Institute of Health he's
held this position since 1984 he's led
the agency's research related to
hiv/aids influenza malaria Ebola and
other infectious diseases he's advised
six presidents on domestic and global
health issues he's one the principal
architect of the Emergency Plan for AIDS
relief in 2014 he was involved in
treating Ebola patients at NIH and
worked on vaccine trials for Ebola next
dr. Robert Redfield director of the u.s.
Center for Disease Control and
Prevention CDC for more than 30 years
he's been involved with clinical
research related to chronic human viral
infections and infectious diseases
especially HIV he was founding director
of the department of retroviral research
within the US military's HIV research
program and retired after 20 years of
service with the US Army Medical Corps
third admiral brett jawad Admiral Gy is
the assistant secretary for health at
the US Department of Health and Human
Services he oversees the development of
the department's public health policy
recommendations specific to Cova 19
response
Admiral juruá has taken on testing and
focused on increasing the number of
tests we can do with existing technology
his federal service includes directing
the defense sciences office of the
Defense Advanced Research Projects
Agency and a variety of other important
responsibilities finally we will hear
from dr. Stephen
hon dr. Hans Commissioner of the US Food
and Drug Administration the FDA before
joining FDA he held leadership positions
as chief medical examiner s'en cancer
center in his chair of the department of
radiation oncology at the University of
Pennsylvania early in his career he was
senior investigator at the National
Cancer Institute at the National
Institutes of Health
he's been commander of the US Public
Health Service commissioned Corps in
2005 we welcome our witnesses
dr. Falchi welcome let's begin with you
thank you very much mr. chairman ranking
member Murray members of the committee
thank you for giving me the opportunity
to discuss briefly with you today the
role of the National Institutes of
Health and research addressing Co vyd 19
and as you indicated mr. Chairman I will
during the question period and alluding
to in the presentation addressed some of
the issues regarding schools the NIAID
nih strategic plan for kovat research
involves four major components the first
is to improve the fundamental knowledge
of understanding of the biology of the
virus and the immune response to the
virus in order to better inform us in
the development of Diagnostics
therapeutics and vaccines some of the
work that has come out of that program
right now informs very greatly
how we will address vaccine development
particularly understanding the
confirmation of the components of the
virus that induce an appropriate immune
response in addition we will develop in
all developing animal models apropos of
what you mentioned about children in
school we have a program called heroes
which is human epidemiology and response
to saws coronavirus which is determining
the incidents and transmissibility among
children a very important issue when you
talk about opening schools and the
impact that might have in addition the
development of Diagnostics point-of-care
sensitive and specific Diagnostics under
the rad x program
including the rat X up for underserved
populations third to characterize and
test their repute --ax you mentioned the
importance of this as we open up schools
there are a number of programs very
active that have already shown efficacy
or not in some drugs as well as a number
of clinical trials that are ongoing one
in particular was the first randomized
placebo-controlled trial showing that
the drug Ren de Sevilla diminishes by
about 32 percent the time it takes to
get to recovery and people with advanced
disease pulmonary involvement in
addition we have another study combining
this with an anti-inflammatory agent
next we have vaccines as several have
mentioned it's extremely important to
have safe and effective vaccines
available for everyone in this country
as well as globally in that regard we
put together myself and some of my
colleagues and published in science
magazine a few weeks ago what we call a
strategic approach to coronavirus 19
vaccine research and development it's
not a comprehensive plan about every
aspect of vaccine but it is a strong
plan regarding the research and
development pathway and what we have
done in this is that we have what's
called a harmonized effect because we
know there were many vaccines that are
in trial now at various stages and what
we did and the federal government thanks
the generosity of the Congress has put a
considerable amount of money in order to
harmonize the trials of multiple
candidates from different companies so
that we have common endpoints common
dative and safety monitoring board and
common immunological parameters that are
being funded and are being pursued in
addition there are a number of different
platforms that are being pursued so that
we don't have all our eggs in one basket
as you know one of those is right now
getting ready as we approach next month
of going into Phase three trials and
others will be staggered along the way
in the middle of the summer
the summer early on there was no
guarantee and anyone has been involved
in vaccinology will tell you that we
will have a safe and effective vaccine
but we are cautiously optimistic looking
at animal data and the early preliminary
data that we will at least know the
extent of efficacy sometime in the
winter and early part of next year again
working with the companies in the
investment made by this Congress
hopefully there will be doses available
by the beginning of next year these are
the things that we feel aspirationally
hopeful about and we would continue to
pursue this I'll stop there mr. chairman
and be happy to answer questions later
thank you thank you dr. Falchi dr.
Redfield welcome good morning chairman
Alexander ranking member Murray and
distinguished members of the committee I
want to thank you for the opportunity to
testify before you today with my HHS
colleagues the coven 19 pandemic is the
most significant global public health
challenge that we have faced as a nation
in more than a century in the United
States daily cases are increasing after
an extended decline we're seeing
significant increases in the southeast
and southwest regions of this nation the
number of jurisdictions in upward
trajectory has continued to increase now
29 of 55 jurisdictions fall into this
category
the evidence tells us that these cases
are driven by many factors to include
increased testing community transmission
and outbreaks in the settings such as
nursing homes and occupational settings
hospitalizations now are going up in 12
states and as of this weekend daily
death now has increased in the state of
Arizona
CDC is closely monitoring these increase
and have 48 teams with more than 140
staff currently deployed in 20 states
and two territories CDC is providing
technical expertise to the health
departments and epidemiology contact
tracing infection prevention and control
and communication beyond providing this
critical boots on the ground CDC is
working with your
and community in other ways CDC is
speaking with the state's tribal local
and territorial health departments on a
daily basis to develop strategies to
stop COBIT while reopening businesses
and schools the initial guidance for
Institutes of higher learning which
shared in March in the K through 12
setting was shared in February
both these guidances have been updated
since and over the past several months
as more information becomes available
we'll continue to disseminate that more
broadly CDC release consolidated
recommendations for kovat testing
including interim testing guidelines for
nursing homes as well as testing options
for high-density critical infrastructure
workplaces after a Kovach case is
identified testing guidance for higher
education and K through 12 the kate
higher education should be posted today
in K through 12 later this week these
recommendations are consistent with
previously published testing guidelines
and are meant to supplement not replace
the guidance of local jurisdictions CDC
continues to advance science around the
Kovan 19 impact in certain populations
and those who are at heightened risk for
severe outcomes
our most recent analysis of the United
States case data fanned the pandemic
hospitalizations were six times higher
and death twelve times higher among
those with reportedly underlying
conditions compared to those who did not
have these conditions we've expanded the
list of underlying conditions where the
evidence is clear that they put people
at higher risk of severe illness these
conditions include chronic kidney
disease COPD having a weakened immune
system from insolvent organ transplant
obesity serious heart disease sickle
cell disease and type 2 diabetes our
analysis Dallas's also provides further
evidence and evidence that racial and
ethnic populations are
disproportionately affected by this
epidemic
while date is the backbone of this
response containing the outbreak depends
on four core interventions readily
available testing comprehensive contact
tracing timely isolation of known cases
and quarantined to break the
transmission we are not defenseless
against this disease
we have powerful tools at our disposal
social distancing wear face cover in
public and be disciplined about the
frequent hand-washing it is critical
that we all take the personal
responsibility to slow the transmission
of COBIT 19 and embrace the universal
use of face coverings specifically I'm
addressing the younger members of our
society the Millennials and your
generation Z's I ask those that are
listening to spread the word before I
close I'd like to speak briefly about
how CDC is assisting the front lines of
our health departments to fight Kovan
with your support
CDC has awarded 12 billion dollars to 64
jurisdictions data monetization is
underway public health laboratories are
building resilience number of contact
tracers have grown 345 percent the
disease impacts us all and it's going to
take all of us working together to stop
it together I believe we can achieve the
possible thank you and I look forward to
your questions
thank you dr. Redfield Admiral Jawad
welcome chairman Alexander ranking
member Murray and distinguished members
of the committee it's good to see all of
you again first I want to clarify my
current role on March 12th secretary
azar requested that I lead the
coordination of kovat 19 testing efforts
within the department to be clear
although I am assuming some of my
traditional duties as the assistant
secretary I am maintaining my role
coordinating testing including now the
NIH red X Diagnostics program along with
dr. Collins to assure that innovations
are immediately translated into practice
in order to get back safely to work
in school the overarching most critical
and essential action we must first
accomplish is to control the virus
meaning rapidly extinguishing any
outbreaks and minimizing community
transmission all of us are concerned
about recent data from several states
indicating rising infections and now an
uptick in hospitalizations and deaths
even as other states and the majority of
counties are maintaining a low infection
burden knowing what we know now about
asymptomatic transmission and the fact
that we are in a much better position
today in terms of our mitigation
strategies PPE and testing we can
reverse these concerning trends if we
work together first
we must take personal responsibility and
be disciplined about our own behavior
maintain physical distancing wear a face
covering whenever you can't physically
distance wash your hands stay at home if
you feel sick if you have been in close
contact with someone infected or in a
gathering without appropriate
precautions get tested shield the
elderly and the vulnerable of any age
and follow the guidelines for opening up
America again the criteria are very
specific and are as relevant today as
when we release them in addition this
week we are initiating surge testing in
multiple communities of highest concern
in coordination with state and local
officials now back to schools and
businesses as dr. Redfield stated the
CDC will release recommendations on K
through 12 institutions of higher
education and general business reopening
these will include considerations for
integrating testing especially
surveillance testing into a
comprehensive strategy as you asked me
mr. chairman if you are a superintendent
of a school system or a president of a
university number one apply the CDC
guidelines in consultation with your
state and local public health officials
so that testing is a part of your
comprehensive plan which should also
include prevention and clear mechanisms
to isolate positive students number to
assure your testing needs are
incorporated into your state testing
plans as we outlined in the national
testing strategy each state has
developed and will continue to build
upon a customized to state testing plan
developed in full coordination with the
federal government the next iterate
covering July to December is due on July
10th these state plans drive the
allocation of certain scarce resources
for example in May and June
the federal government has distributed
nearly twenty-six million collection
swabs in over 19 million tubes of
transport media HHS also prioritizes
allocation of certain key laboratory
tests like point-of-care tests according
to state specific needs
there are also strategies particularly
relevant to surveillance testing
especially in universities and
businesses for example pooling of
samples meaning combining two or more
samples and possibly up to ten into a
single test makes sense where the
prevalence of infection is low in such
pooled surveillance testing can be
conducted in a university research lab
outside of a CLIA environment but if a
pooled sample is positive for kovat
every individual in that pool would need
to be tested through a Health System I
would like to close by recognizing my
fellow officers in the United States
Public Health Service commissioned Corps
the uniformed service that I lead 4536
officers have deployed to support the
pandemic response exemplifying the care
and compassion that all of us feel for
those who have suffered during this
pandemic I thank each and every one of
these officers and their families and on
their behalf
sincerely thank all of you in Congress
for supporting our training needs an
establishment of a Ready Reserve Corps
to supplement our ranks during
inevitable future national emergencies
thank you for the opportunity to provide
these remarks thank you
Thank You Admiral JaJuan welcome dr.
Hahn Thank You chairman Alexander a
ranking member Mary and members of the
help committee I appreciate very much
the support that you all have provided
for our efforts during this time of Cova
nineteen FDA has a vital role in the
federal government's response to the
pandemic one of our core missions is to
advance the public health by helping to
speed medical products that are safe and
a
we have provided appropriate regulatory
flexibilities to assure that the
American public has access to critical
metal prop medical products and safe
food and confidence that our decisions
are based on medicine and science since
the public health emergency was declared
FDA has issued more than 100 emergency
use authorization for diagnostic tests
personal protective equipment
ventilators other devices and drug
products and we have issued more than 50
guidance documents to ensure the
continuity of health care in the food
supply I am pleased to announce that
today FDA is taking action to aid the
time timely development of a safe and
effective vaccine to prevent Cova 19 by
providing guidance for developers with
recommendations on the data needed to
facilitate manufacturing clinical
development and approval we recognize
the urgent need to develop a safe and
effective vaccine to prevent covin 19:00
and we want to work collaboratively with
industry researchers and other partners
to accelerate these efforts while the
FDA is committed to help expedite this
work we will not cut corners in our
decision-making and we are making clear
in our guidance what are the day that we
need that should be submitted to meet
our regulatory standards of approval
this is particularly as important as we
know that some people are skeptical of
vaccine development efforts the FDA
strongly encourages the inclusion of
diverse populations in all phases of
clinical development including
populations most affected by Cova 19 and
specifically racial and ethnic
minorities as well as adequate
representation in late phase trials of
elderly individuals and those with
medical comorbidities we also have
information in this guidance about
including women who are pregnant as well
as for pediatric assessments of safety
and effectiveness the American people
should know that we have not lost sight
of our responsibility to maintain our
regulatory independence and ensure that
our decisions related to all medical
products including Kotov and 19 vaccines
are based on sound science and the
available
this is a commitment the American public
can have confidence in and that I will
continue to uphold personally while
vaccine research is ongoing rapid
testing and therapeutic development can
aid in the safe return to school college
and the workplace
FDA is constantly evaluating new data we
receive on testing so that we can
promote the development of new and
better tests and remove tests that are
not reliable from the market and we have
put into a place an initiative to
accelerate the development of treatments
called the coronavirus treatment
acceleration program or C tab we've seen
some of the consequences of that program
such as the authorization of REM des
Vere and the recent information
regarding other therapeutics that might
be a benefit to patients with Koba 19:00
we are working day and night to provide
guidance to and review proposals from
companies scientists and researchers who
are developing therapies for covin 19:00
we are now preparing for the next phase
of addressing this evolving crisis it is
mission-critical that the agency
constantly evaluate whether our
processes are maximal to promote and
protect the public health and therefore
we are beginning a comprehensive
real-time review and assessment of our
actions to date to address the Cova 19
panic pandemic and I'm glad to answer
questions about that review I want to
thank the more than 17,000 FDA employees
who have been working night and day to
help expedite medical products but also
to provide the necessary oversight with
the appropriate science and data we know
that the virus remains with us FDA is
committed to doing the critical work
that will get the country to the point
at which Americans judge it safe to
return to work and school as quickly as
possible I am incredibly proud of the
dedicated women and men of the FDA whose
commitment to defeating this pandemic
has been unwavering I can assure you the
FDA will continue to provide leadership
expertise guidance and information as we
continue to address this unprecedented
challenge and fulfill our mission to
protect and promote public health thank
you and appreciate and look forward to
your questions
thank you dr. Han and thanks to each of
our witnesses will now begin around a
5-minute questions
all the senators are participating today
almost all and so I would ask the
Senators and two witnesses to try to
keep each segment within five minutes
dr. Falchi assumed I'm superintendent of
one of 14,000 school districts and in
our community we we understand that
their health risks for children going
back to school but we've concluded that
the risk of to their education mental
health and social development is a
greater risk if they don't go back to
school so what would your advice be to a
school superintendent about what he or
she should be thinking about as children
go back to school in a few weeks to keep
them safe thank you for that question
mr. chairman it is an important question
but I think we need to point out that it
really will depend on the dynamics of
the outbreak in the particular location
where the school is and one of the
things we want to emphasize and have
been emphasizing is to take a look at
where you are in the particular area of
the so called opening America again are
you at the gateway phase 1 phase 2 phase
3 the CDC has guidelines about the
opening of schools at various stages of
those checkpoints the basic fundamental
goal would be as you possibly can to get
the children back to school and to use
the public health efforts as a tool to
help get children back to school let me
explain what I mean in other words if we
adhere to guidelines of what we've heard
in many of these presentations you just
heard about the physical distance in the
community the use of masks things like
that that will help to keep the level of
infection in the community down which
will then make it easy to get the
children back to school if you are in an
area where you have a certain amount of
infection dynamics
there are things that can creatively be
done about modifying things like the
school schedule alternate days morning
versus evening allowing under certain
circumstances online virtual lessons
those are the kind of things that we
need to consider but also importantly
always make the goal that it is very
important to get the children back to
school for the unintended negative
consequences that occur when we keep
them out of school thank you doctor fat
dr. Redfield one of the concerns would
be that children who generally speaking
haven't been damaged nearly as much as
adults particularly elderly adults by
this virus might carry the virus to
their teachers administrators or parents
or grandparents at home seems to me that
the availability of treatments this fall
medicine for the environments that
reduce the risk of sickness and death
could be very important in increasing
confidence in going back to school you
mentioned some of those in your
testimony are there others what will the
availability of treatments be this fall
and specifically what about so-called
antibody cocktails of the kind that were
developed for Ebola and approved by the
FDA well I think that'd be a great
question also for dr. pouchy I'm gonna
make a small statement he may want to
add to it clearly we do have reduce of
air as you mentioned we have now
evidence that steroids can improve
therapy and as you mentioned we have
convalescent plasma that Steve Hannon
could comment on that's the using the
the antibodies from individuals that
have gotten better from kovat that are
currently under evaluation and
potentially be available I have just a
minute dr. Redfield let me go to dr.
Hahn and let him answer that question -
thank you as I mentioned REM des Vere
has been authorized based on its
reduction in hospitalization days
the steroids were mentioned convalescent
plasma we have evaluated the safety
through a large expanded access program
at the Mayo Clinic and it's been found
to be safe in over 20,000 patients who
administered it we are waiting for the
safety data and we will be passing those
data along to Barda who's the sponsor of
that program I think that antibody data
will help us in terms of the development
of monoclonal antibodies we have a
number of sponsors who have come in for
monoclonal antibody studies we are
already well into that treatment
monoclonal antibodies are synthetic
antibodies that will provide that the
theory's will provide protection against
the infection of the virus and we're
hopeful that those studies by the late
summer early fall will provide us
information about their effectiveness
and safety so you're optimistic that
there will be more than one treatment
available this fall for teachers
administrators older adults
yes sir I'm optimistic thank you very
much senator Murray thank you very much
to all of our witnesses we owe very much
appreciate your service in your work dr.
Sachi
last time you testified testified before
this committee you warned us of needless
suffering and death if states begin
reopening too early and just over a
month later now we are seeing a record
number of cases we do not have enough
tests and we did not have enough contact
tracers and just yesterday CDC's doctor
chuckit said we have too much virus to
control in the u.s. arguing and I quote
this is really the beginning our
strategy hasn't worked I want to ask you
what did the federal government and the
more than 30 states with rising case
numbers need to do to reverse this trend
thank you very much for that question
senator Murray I am also quite concerned
about what we are seeing evolve right
now in several of the states as you know
in four of the states in Florida Texas
California and Arizona more than 50% of
the new infections are in those areas
where we're seeing surgeons the things
we need to do I think you alluded
in your question to me we've got to make
sure that when states start to try and
open again they need to follow the
guidelines that have been very carefully
laid out with regard to checkpoints what
we've seen in several states are
different iterations of that perhaps
maybe in some going too quickly and
skipping over some of the checkpoints
but even in states in which the
leadership in the form of the governor's
and the mayor's did it right with the
right recommendations what we saw
visually in clips and in photographs of
individuals in the community doing it
all a nun phenomenon which is dangerous
and by all a nun I mean either be locked
down or open up in a way where you see
people at bars not wearing masks not
avoiding crowds not paying attention to
physical distancing I think we need to
emphasize the responsibility that we
have both as individuals and as part of
a societal effort to end the epidemic
that we all have to play a part in that
and they think if you look at the
visuals what we saw were a lot of people
who maybe felt that because they think
they are invulnerable and we know many
young people are not because they're
getting serious disease that therefore
they're getting infected has nothing at
all to do with anyone else when in fact
it does because if a person gets
infected they may not be symptomatic but
they could pass it to someone else
who passes it to someone else who then
makes someone's grandmother grandfather
sick uncle or a leukemic child on
chemotherapy gets sick and died we've
got to get that message out that we are
all in this together and if we are going
to contain this we've got to contain it
together well I assume that would mean
that elected and community leaders need
health behavior and wear a mask
we recommend masks for everyone on the
outside anyone who comes into
contact in a crowded area you should
avoid crowds where possible and when
you're outside and not have the
capability of maintaining distance you
should wear a mask at all times
thank you dr. Redfield last week dr.
julie gerber dean who served as a CDC
director under president george w bush
testified to our committee that if she
were in charge one of her top priorities
would be the creation of a National
Vaccine plan that addresses the science
development allocation uptake and
monitoring of a vaccine saying quote we
know this is in our future and we are
not ready for it I couldn't agree more
and that plan has to detail how the
federal government will scale up
manufacturing coordinate the supply
chain so we avoid the missteps we saw
with testing needs to combat
misinformation and vaccine hesitancy and
make sure that vaccine distribution
addresses health disparities and a lot
more dr. Redfield do you agree a plan
like that is needed senator I think it's
very important that we have a integrated
plan for this vaccine when can we well
I'm gonna ask dr. Hahn if you'd like to
comment I know recently they had a
vaccine plan for at least four the FDA's
perspective CDC is working on the issues
that you said that I think are so
important in building vaccine will be
giving us their plans CDC would be
writing the comprehensive plan will
we're developing a plan as we as we
speak and again to be building on the
efforts that we have to rebuild what I
call vaccine confidence in this country
which is really critical and then on top
of that there'll be a very defined plan
for distribution of this vaccine
prioritization of this vaccine well it's
currently in development within the
group and I you know I'd anticipate that
we'll see that plan in the in the near
weeks of heads head senator
weeks not days months in the weeks ahead
it's a collective effort that we're
doing together within the concept of
operation Wharf speed but CDC's been
working on this plan
literally for probably the last 10 to 12
weeks
Oh mr. Chairman I would just say we need
to see that plan we need to know what it
is the American public needs to know
what that is communities need to know
what that is so I hope that we urge that
plan to be public as soon as possible so
we all know what to expect
thank you senator Murray senator burr
Thank You mr. chairman after working on
pandemic policy now for 17 years I'm
reminded this morning Tony felt she's
been doing it twice as long as I have
and most of you at the tas have been
doing that as well
I urge my colleagues pay attention to
what each of these individuals say
because some things are predictable up
here Congress is a full-fledged partner
and funds things when there's an urgent
need a threat that's out there and I
know Tony you've seen over the years
when there's not that threat out there
things get shelved like platforms that
we could have developed and have better
countermeasures today platforms that
then could address vaccines in a much
faster pace than maybe what we're doing
but we spend more time with the blame
game than we do with focuses on how the
future should look while all of us
members of Congress and people within
government wish that we could get back
to normalcy your agencies and members of
Congress are also charged with making
sure that we mapped the future so the
future generations have better
protections in what we have and that's
why I applaud the chairman for his white
paper and I would encourage every member
of that Dyess to be brutally honest with
us about where changes need to be made
and where they don't need to be made dr.
Redfield I think you would agree with me
that testing and surveillance on this
has not been
the best performance by CDC I don't want
to dwell on where we've come up short
share with these members and myself what
can we expect over the next several
months from CDC that will be different
than what the past has looked like well
thank you senator for your question
I think CDC will continue to work with
the state local tribal territory health
departments to build their capacity I
think we all know that for decades
there's been consistent under investment
in public health in this nation and the
core capabilities to do that job data
data monitor is a ssin predictive data
analysis laboratory resilience workforce
very appreciative for the merchants ii
response find that congress provided
these are critical infrastructure issues
that the reality are have been under
invested the cdc is right now probably
providing 50 to 70% of all public health
funding to each state we need to have a
much more robust investment in these
core capabilities what you are going to
see because of the Congress acting CDC
has provided now 12 billion dollars to
the local state territorial tribal
health departments to begin to build
that core capability that we would have
liked to built over the last several
decades so that there's enhanced testing
is it's been mentioned it's complicated
here because this virus is so
asymptomatic for so many so the
traditional methods of diagnosis contact
tracing isolation are going to be
inhibited for many individuals and
that's going to require broader
community based surveillance strategies
those plans as was mentioned by the
Admiral are we've received them for June
and July we're working with the local
jurisdictions they're gonna have him in
middle July for the plans for the rest
of the year and we're gonna be working
side by side with them to continue to
augment the public health capacity
responded as kovin virus with basically
enhanced surveillance and enhanced early
diagnosis contact tracing isolation to
begin to bring this outbreak under
control I hope some of that money will
be used to upgrade
systems at CDC that are antiquated sir I
agree with you there I mean I think as
those of you know when I was given the
opportunity to do this job very early on
within a month I recognized that the
core capabilities however our public
health infrastructure is not there
particularly the one that I know you've
been very supportive of data data
monetization predictive data analysis
and and that is in progress
it can't happen too soon and we're
appreciative of the support that
Congress has given and I do think it's
fundamentally critical to bring our data
system and as you know the data
personnel that we have and we thank you
for your efforts there and as we need to
hire those individuals strategically we
will continue to do that
to make sure that the premier public
health agency in this country has the
personnel and data systems that it does
need but I will say the other big issue
we have to correct is to make sure our
public health state local territorial
tribal have that integrated health
system of data dr. Hahn I think you have
used your authorities under Papa at FDA
in a very effective way and the FDA's
risen to the challenge during the public
health emergency cutting red tape and
maintaining the agency's goals standard
for review of life-saving medical
products you've specifically mentioned
innovative trial clinical trial designs
and the use of real world data as areas
where the FDA has gained ground during
the response to covent how do you plan
to ensure that this progress is
maintained long after the coronavirus
response is over thank you senator burr
critical issues that you bring up in
addition some of the things that we're
doing on the review side to actually
expedite review and work with innovators
and developers we will continue part of
our review of our actions to date so a
mid action review will inform how we
move forward no question the fact that
real-world evidence and modernization of
our data systems are needed particularly
on supply chain and demand for medical
products but also on the review cycle
and the innovative clinical design
trials as you mentioned thank you for
that mr. chairman I do hope that you
were
another member will allow dr. Falchi at
some point today to make any comments on
the reports that there's a new swine flu
that the Chinese have apparently
identified and how that might affect us
in the future in this country
well dr. Falchi why don't you do that
now if you have anything to say about a
swine flu the Chinese over the last week
or two have identified a virus in the
environment it has not yet shown to be
infect the humans but it is exhibiting
what we call reassortment capabilities
in other words when you get a brand new
virus that turns out to be a pandemic
virus it's either due to mutations and
or the reassortment or exchanges of
genes and they're seeing virus in swine
in pigs now that have characteristics of
the 2009 h1n1 of the original 1918 which
many of our flu viruses have remnants of
that in it as well as segments from
other hosts like swine when they all mix
up together and they contain some of the
elements that might make them
susceptible to being transmitted to
humans you always have the possibility
that you might have another swine flu
type outbreak as we had in 2009 it's
something that still is in the stage of
examination it's not so called an
immediate threat where you're seeing
infections but it's something we need to
keep our eye out on just the way we did
in 2009 with the emergence of the swine
flu
it's called G 4 is the name of it Thank
You senator Sanders thank you very much
the Chairman and let me thank all of our
panelists for being here and for the
great work that they are doing on this
pandemic oh let me ask a question that
has just bothered me lately all of you
and I think most Americans understand
how important social distancing is we're
told over you know
again the chairman told us at the
beginning of this meeting stay apart at
least six feet apart if you can and just
the other day however American Airlines
announced that they were gonna fill up
all of their planes and other airlines
have done the same so you're gonna have
people going from New York to California
five six hours sitting inches apart from
each other and then you got buses all
over America where people are kind of
packed in like sardines
my question is why hasn't the government
whether it's the CDC or the Department
of Transportation issued guidelines
prohibiting those violations of what we
all know to be common sense once the
doctor Pao sure you want to start on
there Thank You senator well I'm I'm not
the CDC but I'd be happy to make a
comment on that and maybe Bob would also
I mean obviously that is something that
is of concern I'm not sure exactly what
went into that decision making I would
hope there would be something to
mitigate against that because I know as
we've said and I continue to repeat it
that avoiding crowds staying distance
and when in a situation like that wear a
mask I think in the confines of an
airplane that becomes even more
problematic I understand the mask thing
but doesn't it sound a little bit silly
and a little bit in violation of
everything you guys have been talking
about have people sitting next to each
other for five or six hours in an
airplane or crowded into a bus and my
question is why hasn't you know the
president issues a lot of executive
orders why haven't we stopped that type
of activity and told the airlines and
bus companies that is unhealthy senator
I appreciate your question and I think
it's it's a critical area I can tell you
that when they announce that the other
day obviously there was substantial
disappointment with American Airlines
number of the airlines had decided to
keep the middle seat saying I can't say
this is under critical review right now
by us at CDC
we don't think it's the right message as
you pointed out again we think it's
really important in individuals that are
in whether it's a bus or a train or a
plane or a social distancing to degree
that's feasible and at least have a
reliable face covering so okay well I
thank you and I just hope very much that
the CDC or the appropriate agency
basically tells these companies that
that is unacceptable behavior they're
endangering the lives of the American
people let me go to another question I
just have a few more questions and not a
lot of time so I'd appreciate brief
answers at the University of Washington
the Institute of Health they're
indicated that if ninety five percent of
the American people were to wear masks
we could save some 30,000 lives a number
of countries including South Korea
France Turkey and Austria have provided
low-cost or free masks to all of their
people something that I believe in
would you support an effort to greatly
increase the production of high-quality
masks in this country and distribute
them free of charge to every household
in America don't about you or anybody
else wants to jump in on that yes of
course I think masks is are extremely
important and we keep hammering home and
I think what you just mentioned this is
is important there's no doubt that
wearing masks protects you and gets you
to be protected so it's people
protecting each other anything that
furthers the use of masks whether it's
giving out free masks or any other
mechanism I am thoroughly in favor of
and I just want to echo that the senator
in my opening statement again I've
called on an environment that we have
universal masks
I think it's fundamentally the most
important thing we can do that's great
but when you refer to a quote-unquote
universal masks which I agree with you
on would you be supporting the increased
production of high-quality masks and
basically distributing free of charge to
every household in America because I
think that's gonna save kenseth
of lives would you agree so senator
Sanders this is a Beretta why yes are I
agree that that that is very important
because we need to support mask-wearing
I would also point out that dr. Cadillac
the asper has contracted for hundreds of
millions of cloth face coverings - that
could be distributed around the country
and those kinds of processes are being
thought of when I'm not in uniform I
wear them they're white they work very
effective and I think there are a great
investment for the American people
good thank you my very last question
it's an issue I've raised on for the
last couple of months all of us hope to
god that a good safe vaccine will be
developed as soon as possible but that
vaccine may not mean anything to a
low-income person who might not be able
to afford it I happen to believe that we
should make these vaccines and by the
way as you all know federal government
our tax dollars are going to the tune of
billions of dollars into drug companies
to help develop this vaccine that's ok
but don't you Duke would you agree with
me and after that kind of investment we
should make sure that every American
every person in this country can get a
vaccine regardless of their income yes
anybody else want to comment on that yes
senator yes sir well good thank you all
very much
Thank You senator Sanders senator Paul
thank you
fatal conceit is the concept that
central planning with decision making
concentrated in a few hands can never
fully grasp the millions of complex
individual interactions occurring
simultaneously in the marketplace it is
a fatal conceit to believe any one
person or small group of people has the
knowledge necessary to direct an economy
or dictate public health behavior I
think government health experts during
this pandemic need to show caution in
their prognostications it's important to
realize that if society
meekly submits to an expert and that
expert is wrong a great deal of harm may
occur when we allow one man's policy or
one group of small men and women to be
foisted on an entire nation
take for example government experts who
continue to call for schools and daycare
to stay closed or that recommend
restrictions that make it impossible for
a school to function for a time there
may not have been enough information
about coronavirus and children but now
there is there are examples from all
across the United States in the world
that showed that young children rarely
spread the virus let's start in Europe
22 countries have reopened their schools
and have seen no discernible increases
in cases these graphs behind me show no
surge when schools open the red line is
where the schools opened there is data
from Austria Belgium Denmark France
Germany Netherlands no spike when
schools are opened contact tracing
studies in China Iceland
Britain and the Netherlands failed to
find a single case of child to adult
infection here at home child care for
essential workers continued to be
available in some states throughout the
pandemic Brown University researchers
collected data on daycares that remained
open during the pandemic over 25,000
kids in their study found that only 0.16
percent got Kovan and when you looked at
the confirmed cases for staff there was
about 1% of more than 9,000 staff the
YMCA also has put forward statistics
40,000 kids at 1,100 sites there were no
reports of coronavirus outbreaks or
clusters dr. Joshua Sharfstein of Johns
Hopkins writes there is converging
evidence that the corona virus doesn't
transmit among children like the flu
that it is a lower risk just yesterday
the American Academy of Pediatrics says
we got to get kids back in school we
want them physically president school
they even site ma'am
evidence that children are less likely
to contract the virus ultimately this
all comes down to the fatal conceit that
central planners have enough knowledge
somehow to tell a nation of 330 million
people what they can and can't do
perhaps our planners might think twice
before they weigh in on every subject
perhaps our government experts might
hold their tongue before expressing the
opinion whether we can play NFL football
or major league baseball not in October
perhaps our experts might think twice
before telling the whole world that a
covert vaccine likely won't provide herd
immunity we don't know why I weigh in
with these opinions that we have no
knowledge of these are forecasts that
may well be wrong perhaps our experts
might consider the undue fear they are
instilling in teachers who are now
afraid to go back to work no one knows
the answers to these questions we
shouldn't presume that a group of
experts somehow knows what's best for
everyone
Hayek had it right only decentralized
power and decision-making based on
millions of individualized situations
can arrive at what risks and behaviors
each individual should choose that's
what America was founded on not a herd
with a couple of people in Washington
all telling us what to do and we'd like
sheep blindly follow this all begs the
question what are we gonna tell the
people the truth that it's okay to take
their kids back to school
dr. Falchi every day virtually every day
we seem to hear from you things we can't
do but when you're asked can we go back
to school I don't hear much certitude at
all I hear well maybe it depends all of
this body of evidence about schools
around the world shows there's no surge
all of the evidence shows that it's rare
I mean we've so politicized this and
made it politically correct that the
whu-oh releases that it's rare and you
have a scientist up there honestly
giving her opinion what happens to her
she's blackballed and her a report that
she refers to was taken off the website
when you go to that that scientist
speech in you and you
try to lick link on the lick the whu-oh
has now screened it from us because it
said something that's not politically
correct it guess what it's rare for kids
to transmit this but I hear nothing of
that coming from you all I hear doctor
foul cheese we can't do this we can't do
that we can't play baseball even that's
not based on the science
I mean flu season peaks in February we
don't know that kovat is gonna be like
the flu season it might but we don't
know that but we wouldn't we wouldn't
ban school in October you might close
some schools when they get the flu we
need to not mean to so from sumptuous
that we know everything but my question
to you is can't you give us a little bit
more on schools that we can get back to
school that there's a great deal of
evidence and it's actually good good
evidence the kids aren't transmitting
this it's rare and the kids are staying
healthy and yes we can open our schools
it's the chairman do I have a little bit
of time to give you a little over five
minutes but thank you so much yeah so
very quickly Senator Paul I I agree with
a lot of what you say about you know
this idea about people having to put
their opinions out without data and
sometimes you you have to make
extrapolations because you're in a
position where you need to at least give
some sort of recommendation but if you
were listening and I think you were to
my opening statement and my response to
one of the questions I feel very
strongly we need to do whatever we can
to get the children back to school so I
think we are in Lock agreement with that
the other thing that I'd like to clarify
very briefly is that I when things get
in the press of what I supposedly said I
didn't say I never said we can't play a
certain sport what happens is that
people in the sport industry they could
either be people from Players
Association owners people involved in
the health of the plays ask me opinions
regarding certain facts about the spread
of the virus what the dynamics are I
give it and then it gets interpreted
that I'm saying you can't play this
sport or you can't play that sport I
agree with you I am completely
unqualified to
you whether you can play a sport or not
the only thing that I can do is to the
best of my ability give you the facts
and the evidence associated with I know
about this outbreak thank you thank you
we just need more optimism there mr.
chairman very much for the hearing and I
want to thank our witnesses for their
public service mr. chairman let me start
with dr. Hahn then I'll move to Admiral
gerar dr. Hahn I wanted to ask you about
vaccines and as your testimony indicates
and as we've been discussing over time
as researchers work to develop vaccines
to protect against Kovan 19 it's
important that the final FDA approved
products have the full confidence of the
American people a vaccine doesn't help
but people don't choose to in fact be
vaccinated so my first question is given
that we've seen very high rates of both
vaccine refusal as well as skepticism
what role can the FDA play in the coming
months to earn the public's trust that
the Cova 19 vaccines are safe and
effective that's question number one
what role the FDA can play and then the
second question is what steps can you
take as FDA Commissioner to bolster
public confidence Thank You senator for
that question I couldn't agree more that
public confidence in vaccines is so
important so to your first question we
have an obligation to use all of our
scientific knowledge our regulatory
framework to ensure that any vaccine
that comes before us whether for
authorization or approval meets our
stringent standards for safety and
effectiveness one of the reasons that we
issued that guidance that I mentioned in
my opening statement was to provide
regulatory clarity around what FDA
expects with respect to those data we
want to see certain parts of those data
so that we can demonstrate to the world
to the nation to the American people
that we are following our
standards with respect to safety and
efficacy the other thing that we've done
is draw a very bright line between FDA
and our regulatory independence and all
the sponsors who are putting forth
vaccine applications to us and that
includes operation warp-speed so we are
providing technical assistance to those
sponsors but we are not part of the
decision-making process and we will
maintain our regulatory independence I
will not prejudge the agency will not
prejudge any decision with respect to
this we will use the science and the
data with respect to what I can do
personally senator I commit to you that
I will continue to be a voice
emphasizing the regulatory independence
we have a number of communications in
progress to communicate to the American
people that the standards were going to
uphold our firm they are rooted in
science and data and that they will
ensure that we meet the usual high
standards of FDA with respect to safety
and efficacy thanks very much dr. I
might submit a question for the record
to dr. Redfield as well but just so I
can get my second question and to the
Admiral I want to ask you about testing
and insurance coverage testing as you
know and as we've emphasized in these
hearings is so fundamental in order to
prevent the spread of copán 19 Congress
I think acted upon that knowledge by
mandating full coverage of Cova 19
diagnostic and antibody testing both in
the families first bill
as well as the cares Act we made it
clear that Americans shouldn't have to
pay a dime for Kovan 19 testing but
we're hearing alarming and reports of
people not being tested often for one of
two reasons because they're under the
impression they will have to pay for
testing and patients who have been
tested or receiving surprise medical
bills the administration has issued
guidance that appears to be in conflict
with congressional intent and public
health guidance and so we have some
confusion here I'd ask you Admiral can
you assure the American people
the Department of Health and Human
Services will fulfill the intent of both
the families first bill
in the cares Act and ensure that
American the American people will be
provided wide access to Cova 19 tests
without cost or limitation so thank you
senator and I want to thank all of you
for emphasizing the importance of
testing and eliminating any barriers
that there could be I can't speak for
the department I certainly speak as the
assistant secretary and as the testing
person that we firmly believe and
support the concept of no-cost testing
there should not be a disincentive in
any single way to get the diagnostic
tests that you need to get tested during
screening or sir or the serology tests
as Congress intended so thank you for
that we do need to keep getting that
message out it's a very important one to
have Thank You radical Thank You mr.
chairman Thank You senator Casey
senator Collins thank you very much mr.
chairman and I want to thank all of our
witnesses today for your dedication and
hard work it's really been important the
chairman raised a very important
question about who pays for the testing
when a person has no symptoms and no
known exposure to the virus and I would
add another key question and that is how
are such tests even access these are
critical questions for the reopening of
schools and for the thousands of jobs in
the tourism industry upon which means
economy depends in Maine for tourists to
come and visit that out-of-state visitor
one option is to show a reason
negative kovat test the problem is that
when hotel owners in Maine surveyed
testing sites in ten states they found
that ninety percent of requests for a
test for travel purposes were denied
now this lack of access to tests is
devastating for reopening Maine's
tourism businesses one innkeeper told me
that last year in the month of June she
had an occupancy rate of ninety four
percent this year it was six percent so
you can imagine the impact on employment
at that Inn given the impact on
reopening schools and on jobs in the
tourism and other industries how is the
federal government working with States
to better match demand for testing would
supply and to overcome these Geographic
variations Admiral I would direct that
question to you so so thank you ma'am I
will try to be brief and not to take
much of your time but we were very
careful in our prioritization that we do
prioritize persons without symptoms who
are prioritized by health departments or
clinicians for any reason including
public health monitoring surveillance or
screening of other asymptomatic
individuals according to state local
plan so that is a priority that if it is
important for the state those
asymptomatic individuals can be can be
screened the the second issue just again
to be brief is we work we have worked
individually with every single state to
determine what their state testing needs
are how are they organizing in the
context of the CDC and we are supplying
them with the supplies they need to meet
that so every week shipments of the
basic supplies go to every single state
according to their state testing plan
and we keep a little bit in reserve
right because when there's an outbreak
somewhere that we need to surge we do
have that so for example the state
testing goals for July or somewhere
across the country are about thirteen
point nine million tests is there
first-line goals and we we will match
those state-by-state I hope that you
will help us get the word out to testing
sites in States from which a lot of
tourists usually come to me that would
be very helpful to us
dr. Falchi let me turn to you earlier
this month higher education leaders the
Maine issued a framework for safely
returning to campuses this fall that
recognizes the importance of testing and
the need to include financially
struggling institutions in partnerships
in order to make sufficient testing
protocols possible you last week spoke
about the possibility of the development
of pool testing strategies and as I
understand this but this would allow
more people to be tested using fewer
resources and the medical director of
Stanford's clinical viral viral ology
lab suggests that this makes particular
sense in areas with low rates of kovat
19 where you would expect the large
majority of tests to be negative could
you expand on the possibility of
expanding pull testing and tell us more
about that yes thank you for the
question senator what that really is if
you want to get a feel for the
penetrance of infection in a community
rather than testing multiple each
individual person which takes resources
and times what you do and you can do a
statistical analysis of not losing
sensitivity by pooling let's say 10 or
15 or five together so
put all the tests together and you do
one test if that test is negative then
you know those ten people are all
negative so instead of utilizing 10
tests you've utilized one test then you
get another batch of we'll say ten or so
and if you then find one is positive
then you go back track and figure out
who that person is and if you do the
mathematical calculation you can save a
lot of time a lot of resources and use
the testing for a variety of other
things that you would need so it's a
really good school it can be used in any
of a number of circumstances at the
community level or even in school if you
wanted to do that so apropos of what you
started your comment off with it clearly
can be extrapolated to that thank you so
much that sounds like an excellent
technique for our schools to use thank
you senator Collins senator Baldwin
Thank You mr. chairman I want to thank
all of our witnesses today for joining
us
like so many members of this committee
I'm concerned about new outbreaks and
increasing cases certainly I've seen
them in my home state of Wisconsin and I
know we're seeing that nationally now
CDC and OSHA have issued recommended
safety guidance for businesses but this
guidance is not enforceable many
businesses are truly trying to do the
right thing and protecting workers and
customers and the public that interacts
with those businesses and so I we also
had a previous discussion I think
senator Sanders raised the issue of
American Airlines filling up their
planes versus others that are still not
trying to push to do so because of
safety concerns we also had I think was
Admiral Gerrard hold up the what he
called critical guidance please follow
this critical guidance so dr. Redfield
should we be supporting businesses that
have taken the steps to protect their
workers and customers by fully implement
the cdc's and OSHA's recommended safety
guidance yes or no yes we should be
supporting those businesses now can you
confirm yes or no that all businesses
have adopted and implemented this
guidance says they've opened up I think
senator you know that unfortunately
that's not been the case
so it's an uneven playing field and it
hurts businesses that are trying to do
the right thing by voluntarily adopting
CDC and OSHA safety guidelines because
their competitors don't have to incur
the same safety and health costs and if
you believe that we should be supporting
the good actors then shouldn't we create
a level playing field by issuing an
emergency temporary standard to require
all businesses to adopt and comply with
enforceable safety standards
I made two comments senator first one
it's so important that we've tried to
say is that this is a time that everyone
in our nation accept the responsibility
that dr. Fauci and I spoke about to
recognize they have the fundamental
responsibility not just to protect
themselves to protect others by the
social distance face mask and
hand-washing secondly again as we look
at the local jurisdictions again to see
where in fact that enforceability would
be whether it's in the local health
department the state health department
or the federal health department I think
again we see that the community can get
behind that responsibility those
businesses that support that
responsibility may find in fact their
business is better than those businesses
that don't I can tell you that if you
interrupt you I apologize dr. Redfield
but my time is limited the the panel
right now is composed of people
representing public health and public
health institutions OSHA is our lead
federal agency
for protecting workers safety and health
have you had communication with the
Department of Labor and OSHA about
issuing mandatory enforceable standards
rather than this voluntary guidance
secretary Scalia is a member of the task
force and he's in the discussions with
us that the vice-president chairs that
specific topic yes
we have not had a discussion directly
but we have had discussions and review
of the guidance that we put two
businesses both critical infrastructure
and non critical infrastructure
businesses with OSHA so I I have limited
time left but I do want to say that the
University of Wisconsin announced that
they will be reopening for classes in
the fall they've released a plan called
start smart restart it calls for about
2,000 tests per week on campus
they'll need supplies to do this
including PPE reagents and swabs and
every hearing on kovat 19 we've heard
about shortages of these supplies and
it's why I introduced the medical supply
transparency and delivery act to unlock
the full authority of the defense
production act to increase production of
critical supplies the things that are
needed to conduct widespread testing
Admiral jawar can you describe how
you're working to make sure that
universities and others will have access
to these supplies needed to conduct this
testing in the fall so thank you so much
senator and I want to communicate this
begin I'm happy to work with any
university we coordinate what we give to
the states through the state plan so
it's very important that universities
coordinate through the states and we
supply those materials directly to a
single point of contact in the state who
distributes them we you know we've been
through a lot but we have a lot of swabs
now
partially because of increased domestic
production using the DPA we're
distributing about 20 million swabs per
month we're going to do a lot more than
that um so reagents we do not purchase
centrally because the market is a little
bit more mature so we can trust with an
allocation strategy that we allocate we
support the allocation to different
states depending on their needs so we've
mapped every single machine in every
single state every single County every
single city and unfortunately there's
not enough of one thing that everybody
if they want that can get it so we
really do a matching game to understand
specific state needs for example in
Alaska
it is very rural and there's very
limitations to what they have so we need
to make sure they get what they
absolutely need versus other states that
can be a little bit more flexible so we
do have this thank you very much yes
well I'm afraid we're I'm so well over
well over time we have a large number of
Senators who want to ask questions so I
would renew my request that Senators and
witnesses try to keep the questions and
answers within within five minutes
senator Cassidy hey thank you gentlemen
for all that you're doing I have a
couple slides can you can I ask that the
staff to show the first two slides so
here it shows that we're doing poorly
relative to the countries that are doing
the best and you can argue that Taiwan
is much smaller than week but Taipei is
a very congested City so consider our
cities just collection Taipei's for
example then our Seoul cat South Korea's
it would suggest that what we are
currently doing is less robust and less
whatever adjective you want to use in
the countries that are doing at best
could I have the next slide please and
so this is developed out of a group by a
harbor and just so I can put a plug in
it they will be speaking in our round
table we have Thursday morning and you
can get details from my office if you
wish but kind of that interplay between
collect
doing the testing tracing those you know
compiling your dad I know where your hot
spots are and then Tracy and everyone on
this panel knows how it's done and you
mentioned that you're going to have a
strategy that's coming out later on if
it does beg the question why is it been
so long and I'm not accusing I'm just
curious but this has been developed you
can take a slide down please so knowing
that you're going to develop the
strategy and and kind of build upon
senator byrd mentioned what is the goal
of the strategy is the goal of the
strategy to achieve suppression that's
number one and number two what metrics
will you use and knowing that CDC is the
one who really gives guidance to state
and local governments I'm hoping dr.
Redfield since I'll direct this to you
that it won't be up for the states and
locals to put this plan together but
it'll be the considerable intellectual
firepower of the CDC it gives a pretty
detailed if you have this kind of
community this is what you do if you
have that community that is what you do
because that's the kind of role that CDC
is expected to play dr. Redfield any
thoughts on this thank you very much
senator a very important question first
John your first slide just as a quick
comment and I'll try to be quick I think
it's really important because it doesn't
illustrate back to the comment that we
tried to make of the importance of
personal responsibility to really
practice the social distancing and I'm
gonna ask you just quickly because I
have limited time that's a given but
there has to be a testing aspect of this
because people don't you awaken people
to their responsibilities if they've
know they've been exposed if they don't
know they've been exposed they tend to
be more complacent so please focus upon
the testing data and tracking us but yes
senator initially obviously they can was
early case identification contact Tracy
and isolation obviously testing and
contact tracing without isolation has
little value the challenge has been when
we learned in March that this virus is
significantly asymptomatic
the transmissible then therefore
requiring alternative strategies the
strategy that we're evaluating now is
more of a community LED testing strategy
where you go into a broader community
and you actually test a wide number of
individuals as opposed to it do you have
what metrics are you following is there
a specific strategy that's going to be
given to state and locals is how to
implement this that's very high level
what we need is granularity that's my
question yeah we did the initial
strategy and as I said we're currently
evaluating this community test ledge
strategy in a number of communities now
the metrics are simple it's the percent
cases that are positive we were doing
well there for a while you know the red
but of course if you take the entire
city of New Orleans or Shreveport you're
going to have some that are hot spots
and some that are really fairly safe and
so I'm guess I'm pointing to the
granularity you know should it be a
census tract should it be a hot spot a
building with multifamily housing etc
and just frustrated because when I speak
in my state locals they're not getting
that granularity from CDC that seems to
be where we get to where Seoul South
Korea is and I've not yet heard that as
kind of what we're doing we're sharing
right now at the county level the exact
kinetics we have about 130 counties in
this country out of the more than 5,000
Oh more than 3000 are having trouble and
continuing to get that granularity I
think you've said it senator it's
critical it's got to be a very local
focal response at the granola level dr.
Redfield do we have that granularity
we've been at this for three months
we've got all these data systems we know
where the people live who are tested you
know we have a federated system which
you alluded to earlier is the plan
coming out tonight
that's afternoon going to implement that
granularity I'm over time but if you
would allow mr. chairman for an answer
then I'll see my comment would be that's
where we're going with that granularity
we appreciate some of the changes in
reporting to CDC in terms of testing
that Congress recently did we are now
looking at the granular level we don't
disagree
with the premise behind you it's that
granular response to control those many
outbreaks which is going to be
fundamental to get this under control
Thank You senator senator Cassidy
senator Murphy thank you very much mr.
chairman mr. chairman if this were the
policy of the United States of America
the recommendations and guidelines being
given by our panelists today we would
likely not be in the situation we are
with a virus back on the March spreading
at rapid rates throughout big parts of
the country the problem is our four
panelists do not set the policy of the
United States of America the President
of the United States does and so while
our panelists tell us about the
importance of wearing masks the
president of the United States is
retweeting articles for example entitled
mandatory masks aren't about safety
they're about social control he retweets
people that are criticizing how folks
look when they wear masks though our
panelists today are telling us about the
effectiveness of social distancing the
president united states is holding
rallies all across the country in which
he deliberately prevents people from
distancing his staff ripped signs off of
chairs encouraging people to separate
from each other the president's allies
are out there on TV every day saying
that wearing masks are dehumanizing
somebody said the other day a member of
the house that viruses do what viruses
do the only way you're gonna get
immunity is to get exposed these are the
president's allies trying to curry favor
with him and so we have these two
parallel messaging operations and I just
think it's worth stipulating that
everything we're hearing today is
responsible is based on evidence but the
agencies represented here today have
social-media followings of about five
million people the president United
States has a social media following of
82 million and so you can understand why
folks are confused out there they hear
the recommendations
from dr. Fuji and dr. Redfield but then
they hear the president United States
criticizing a reporter for wearing a
mask because that reporter is being
social is being politically correct
that's why we're in the position we're
in today where you see large numbers of
people not complying with
recommendations because they're hearing
something very different from the chief
executive and they're watching him
behave in a manner and encourage
behavior that is directly contrary to
what we're being told today and it just
probably requires saying that out loud
at this hearing let me ask a few
questions mr. chairman if I can about
global public health because we haven't
covered that here today
doctor foul Qi this virus got here
really quickly and what we learned is
that well travel restrictions can help
or give you time they can't fully
prevent a disease from arriving here and
so even if we do turn the corner in the
United States in a meaningful way so
long as this virus exists in large
quantities outside of the United States
we are still vulnerable is that right
that's correct sir and so dr. Redfield
um what is your understanding of why the
United States has not joined the global
vaccine effort why are we not in
something like sepi an organization that
is working with other nations to try to
coordinate not only the development of
the vaccine but also the distribution of
the vaccine well I think the US has
obviously developed a an aggressive
comprehensive program but senator it
wouldn't preclude being part of these
international organizations also from my
perspective we have legislation pending
right now before the Foreign Relations
Committee that would put the United
States into these global vaccine efforts
it just doesn't make a lot of sense to
many of us on both sides of the aisle as
to why the Trump administration has not
joined and finally Admiral just maybe
help us understand what our relationship
with the w-h-o is today right around the
time that
president declared that we were pulling
out of the WH show not just that we were
not going to fund it but his
announcement was actually we were gonna
sever our relationship of the WI show
you are confirmed to a seat on the
Executive Board and so have you been
recalled from the WH o are you attending
meetings are you participating what are
the details surrounding our withdrawal
from the WH o which by the way is maybe
one of the most dangerous things in my
opinion but the administration has done
in the middle of a global pandemic
what's what's our status and what's your
status ISM as a confirmed member of that
board so thank you senator and I really
do appreciate the confirmation I was
confirmed on that May seventh and I did
attend the Executive Board on May 22nd
the Executive Board it was virtual it
did participate and support our our
multilateral commitments I have not been
recalled I have not been given any
direction to recall myself in any way
there would be another executive board a
meeting probably in October and I
believe all of us on our public health
standards still work with the WH o as a
wh o partner for example we participated
with a wh o on a global sickle-cell
meeting just two days ago so we work we
certainly work from the public health
aspects direction on the official
whether we're going to be a member or
whether I'm not going to go the
executive board I have not gotten that
direction yet okay thank you the
announcement was that we're terminating
our relationship to WH o so probably
some additional clarification would be
helpful Thank You mr. chairman thank you
senator Murphy senator Murkowski Thank
You mr. chairman and gentlemen thank you
for not only your testimony today but
all that you have been doing I think
I've had conversations with each one of
you about the Alaska specific issues
most notably with regards to our our
seafood processing this is the time of
year where we typically welcome a
million-plus tourists as well as
as many thousands that come from from
the lower 48 and other places to help
with our seafood processing and it has
been very anxious time I think for all
of us in Alaska as we see Outsiders
coming in we have seen obviously
elevated cases of confirmed kovat our
numbers I think are enviable when when
other states look at us to know that
we're working about 500 active cases
right now about double that in terms of
what we have seen throughout this whole
pandemic but again we know and you have
stated that we don't have resources that
we can look to to neighboring states
we're kind of on our own island there in
terms of resourcing so what you have
done to help facilitate whether it's the
the plans with the seafood processors
the guidance the the ability to to come
in on an as-needed if the situation so
demands we appreciate that we have seen
the benefit of how these very rigorous
plans have have worked an individual who
comes up to to work in a seafood
processing facility is is tested before
they come to the state they're tested
when they get to the state they're put
in a 14-day quarantine we have seen
positive cases once people have arrived
but we've been able to do what the plan
calls for which is that contact tracing
and then isolation and keeping things to
a minimum so I think it does demonstrate
that these tough plans really can work
they are expensive though if you are
bringing in several hundred or perhaps a
thousand workers and you have to put
them up in a hotel for 14 days with pay
when you have to provide for the health
protocols this is this is costly I would
ask for for your input and probably a
question for the record just in terms of
which agencies
can can best help facilitate these
seafood processors with not only
implementation of the specific guidance
but how we can be dealing with the cost
we do receive some benefit from the
discretionary funds provided to the
states but I think we would all
recognize like the meat pot meat packing
facilities our seafood processors aren't
important in a critical industry not
only to Alaska but to the country so we
want to work to to address that I do
want to speak very quickly though to the
to the public health infrastructure I'm
told that in Alaska as we are doing our
contract taste tracing it is still a
paper copy Excel spreadsheet faxed to
the epidemiology labs this is how we're
doing our tracing I thought well maybe
that's just Alaska and I'm told by by
dr. Zink who you have all had
conversations with that well this is
actually going on in in California as
well that to me is not a contract a
contact tracing system that works and is
sufficient so I want to ask about not
only your view of the sufficiency of of
contact tracing and this is probably to
you dr. Redfield but then dr. pouchy I
want to ask you about the concern that
we have with certain certain parts of
the country where you have public
mistrust of vaccines in general my fear
is that we may get to the place where we
will get to that place where we have
that successful vaccine but we still
have the concern from many and a
mistrust and whether it's vaccine
hesitation or vaccine confidence I don't
know what the buzz word is but I'm
worried that we don't have a plan for
how to deal with that so first contact
tracing and then the vaccine thank you
very much senator I think it's really
important just to highlight what you
said about the current state of data
systems for Public Health in the United
States there
they really are in need of aggressive
modernization and again thank Congress
for the funding there but it is a
substantial investment that needs to
take place there are a number of
counties that are still doing this pen
and pencil as you commented and we need
to have a comprehensive integrated
public health data system that's not
only able to do something that's in real
time but actually can be predictive and
it would be one of the great I think
investments of our time to make that
happen once and for all and that's
really fundamental to to be able to
operationalize contact racy and etc and
contact tracing in this case they'll be
very quick really doesn't have any value
unless you can do it in real time
it doesn't help like I just did with the
airlines where we had people that were
flying infected from Afghanistan and we
didn't get the information till day 14
day 15 day 16 it's irrelevant so again
we love the partnership to get an
integrated public health data system not
just for CDC but for all of our
jurisdictions across the nation into one
timely integrated system senator thank
you for the question about if you can be
succinct we're well over time we'll be
quick we have a community engagement
program that is embedded within the
sites where the vaccine trials will be
done because we're thoroughly aware of
what you're concerned about and it is a
reality a lack of trust of authority a
lack of trust in government and a
concern about vaccines in general we
need to engage the community by boots on
the ground and getting community
particularly those populations that have
not always been treated fairly by the
government minority populations
african-americans Latinos and Native
Americans and we have a program that's
already operable right now to do that
thank you
Thank You senator Murkowski senator
Warren thank you very much mr. chairman
dr. Falchi you came before the help
committee seven weeks ago to discuss the
country's response to the code 19 and
time you told me that the US did not
quote by any means have total control
over this out ring but you also told me
that we were quote going in the right
direction now on the day you testified
before the committee that was May 12
2020 there were about 21,000 new cases
of corona virus yesterday there were
about forty thousand new cases of corona
virus dr. Falchi do these numbers show
that the country is still moving quote
in the right direction and that the
corona virus pandemic is under control
well I think the numbers speak for
themselves although we do have a number
of parts of the country to doing well
I'm very concerned about what's going on
right now particularly in the four
states that are accounting for about
fifty percent of the new infections but
the other vulnerable states so I'd have
to say the numbers speak for themselves
I'm very concerned and I'm not satisfied
with what's going on because we're going
in the wrong direction if you look at
the curves of the new cases so we've
really got to do something about that
and we need to do it quickly
short answer some question is that
clearly we are not in total control
right now thank you thank you very much
you know our case numbers are getting
worse and our death rates are going to
get worse soon during this same period
of time some other countries around the
world have controlled the virus they're
reporting fewer cases each day and they
are able to provide targeted testing and
to keep it up so that they can tell
what's happening and follow-up if there
is an outbreak in other words
controlling the corona virus can be done
but because of bad federal leadership we
have not been able to do this here in
the United States so dr. Fauci the last
time you were before this committee you
told me that if the u.s. did not have
quote an adequate response
that the country would quote have the
deleterious consequences of more
infections and more deaths now I know
that we've made some progress but half
measures won't save lives
dr. pouchy I'm asking you to be very
direct with all of us on this if we
don't fully implement the widespread
testing contact tracing programs and
social distancing practices that
everyone seems to agree that we need can
we expect these spikes and infection to
keep happening in different places
around the country Thank You senator I'm
always direct with you and I'll tell you
in direct answer to your question that
if you look at what's going on and just
look at some of the film clips that
you've seen of people congregating often
without masks of being in crowds and
jumping over and avoiding and not paying
attention to the guidelines that we very
carefully put out we're going to
continue to be in a lot of trouble and
there's going to be a lot of hurt if
that does not stop and that we don't get
our act together more and more
communities around the country are going
to see these dangerous surges of 19.5 a
cat March you also said quote looking at
what we're seeing now you expected there
to be between a hundred thousand and two
hundred thousand coronavirus deaths and
millions of infections in the u.s. so
let's flash forward to late June here we
are at the end of June we've already
seen a hundred and twenty six thousand
deaths with infection rates rising
rapidly dr. Falchi based on what you're
seeing now how many covered 19 deaths
and infections should America expect
before this is all over I can't make an
accurate prediction but it is going to
be very disturbing I will guarantee you
that because when you have an outbreak
in one part of the country even though
in other parts of the country they're
doing well they are vulnerable I made
that point very
clearly last week at a press conference
we can't just focus on those areas that
are having the surge it puts the entire
country at risk we are now having 40
plus thousand new cases a day I would
not be surprised if we go up to a
hundred thousand a day if this does not
turn around and so I am very concerned
can you make any kind of estimate on
what we're looking at overall on the
number of deaths before this is over you
made an estimate back in March between a
hundred thousand and two hundred
thousand but we have a lot more
information now and we're already at a
hundred and twenty six thousand dollars
I I can't make a estimation because that
would have to be modeled out because
when models are done and that's where
those original numbers came from senator
as I've said very often models are as
good as the assumptions that you put
into the model and those assumptions
often change depending upon what your
response is so I would really be
hesitant to give a number that will come
back and either be contradicted and
overblown or under blown but I think
it's important to tell you and the
American public that I'm very concerned
because it could get very bad all right
I appreciate that doctor foul chief what
we all warned I just like the same time
that my Republican colleagues got a lot
more time senator Warren chairman I
always treat you fairly and I would
appreciate your respecting the
Chairman's rules if you'd like to make a
closing statement go ahead and do it but
I don't appreciate your Thank You mr.
chairman in presenting over the years
done that you were allowing more time
since we had such important witnesses
well your chairman you and you can you
can make that you can make those
decisions thank you you know I just want
to make the point that we can't keep
pretending this virus is getting better
when it isn't that's how we end
with methods like the situation in Texas
racing to reopen too soon then
scrambling to close down before the
hospitals get completely overwhelmed if
we don't get our act together this is
our future see-sawing back and forth
between two fuel restrictions and then
exploding cases and repeated shutdowns
in this future thousands more Americans
will die and our economy will be brought
to its knees we've got to have a
national strategy that makes testing
available to every school in business
every hospital every church anywhere
that Americans come together we need to
expand contact tracing and we need
leaders starting with President Trump
who have enough backbone to face reality
distribute our resources set our
standards and stick to them because if
we don't the result is going to be more
economic wreckage and more death Thank
You mr. chairman
thank you senator Warren what I've tried
to do in the in this hearing is to ask
senators to stay within five minutes and
the answers within five minutes and if
if the answers go beyond that I've tried
to be respectful of that but - but I
would ask senators not to ask their
questions into well past five minutes
and then expect to make a speech at the
end
senator Scott I'll Thank You mr.
chairman and I will certainly respect
your your time limits I think we all
should do that and frankly as we were
asking dr. Fauci for an estimate of how
many lives may be a loss I recall the
first estimates were between 1 and 2.4
million lives so I'm certainly glad that
we are not there and perhaps one of the
reasons why we should be thankful for
where we are now and force ourselves to
have a serious conversation about
continuing to flatten the curve is
because the all-hands-on-deck approach
is effective we just need as much
cooperation from as many people as
conceivably possible in every state
around the country in order for us to
see these numbers continue to make it
dive in the right direction as opposed
to spike in the wrong direction and I
think about the operations warp-speed
along with the crucial support
from Barda and other federal agencies
public-private partnerships in
accelerating groundbreaking technologies
that could eradicate Dovan 19 and
revolutionize frankly the vaccine
development landscape because of these
efforts by industry academia and
government working in concert we could
see a viable candidate or candidates in
a matter of months for a vaccine and
because of a growing number of
large-scale manufacturing agreements
with companies like moderna Iser and J&J
producing hundreds of millions of doses
at risk which means in advance we are
already working to address issues of
access and this is critical especially
for our most distressed communities that
said effective development and
widespread access while essential are
only part of the equation if and when
and I feel optimistic that it's wind and
not if we get a viable vaccine we need
to encourage folks to choose to get
vaccinated I was really concerned when I
saw a recent AP survey that showed that
only 49 percent of American adults plan
to get vaccinated
once the Cofield 19 vaccine came to
market a full 20 percent so that they
did not plan to get vaccinated and
one-third of Americans were not sure
given the public's recent and vital
focus on health disparities is worth
noting that among certain groups these
are even more alarming just 25 percent
of black Americans 37 percent of
Hispanic Americans plan to get
vaccinated against the corona virus my
aunt my question to the full panel what
steps can we take at every level of
government and in the private sector
with health care providers to ensure a
proactive education campaign and
outreach strategy on the importance of
getting vaccinated both for covet 19 and
frankly even more broadly I'll take a
shout out at first senator as I
mentioned in response to another
question that we have a community
engagement program
that actually operates out of operation
warp speed the vaccine development
program component of that also there
needs to be engagement of people who the
community trusts particularly
individuals who are noted sports figures
or whomever when we were involved and
continued to be involved in community
engagement with HIV we used people in
the community boots on the ground to go
out who looked and lived and are like
the people there trying to engage it's
very critical because I share with you
the concern that we get to the hoop and
we get through it of getting a safe and
effective vaccine only to find that a
substantial proportion of the population
do not want to get vaccinated of
particular concern is it's that
proportion of the population that
generally are the most vulnerable in the
sense of the minority communities
African Americans latina --cz Native
Americans who in fact because of
underlying conditions make it more
likely that if they do get infected they
would have a poor outcome so it's
extremely important to engage them at
the local level thank you thank you very
much for your answer dr. Koch let me
disclose with my 40 seconds that I have
left and respecting the time and I hope
that we continue to do so the path the
pandemic has triggered a drop of 60 to
80 percent of immunization rates among
children and even now that states are
reopening we're not seeing the rebound
in these rates as that that are
necessary this creates a real risk of
secondary infections and disease
outbreaks that are not on the general
public's radar as we reckon with the
chief crisis at hand so I think it's
incredibly important that we follow your
strategy doctor foul as relates to
engaging community leaders and perhaps
people with notoriety to challenge us to
get involved in taking the vaccines I'll
thank you mr. chairman I apologize for
being four seconds over my time Thank
You senator Scott for respecting the
time we have eight senators
remaining who have questions and we
should have time for all of them to have
a chance to ask your question senator
Kaine Thank You mr. chair and thank you
to the witnesses
dr. Fauci I saw an interview with you
last week where you talked about a
concern that there's two sizable a
percentage of our population that sort
of done like science and scientists and
advice from scientists and I hear real
emotion in your voice as you express
concern about people gathering in large
groups and without masks and I gather
that's the kind of anti science concern
that you were worrying about when you
had that interview last week yeah that
is part of its senator yes because a
disregard of recommendations that come
from authorities only because it's a
recommendation I think the attitude of
pushing back from Authority and pushing
back on scientific data is very
concerning we're in the middle of a
catastrophic outbreak and we really do
need to be guided by scientific
principles and and this could cause
problems down the road if we get to a
vaccine but people don't want to get the
vaccine so we all have to message this
pretty strongly um dr. Redfield I want
to thank you I was going to ask you a
question today that I've been asking
over and over again why does the CDC's
guidance for institutions of higher
education not even mention the word
testing but as soon as your testimony
was done this morning the CDC website
changed and there are now guidelines for
the Institute's of higher education with
fairly extensive recommendations and
guidance that mandates about testing I
didn't have a chance to read them but I
saw them popped up on the CDC website
and I wanted to thank you for that your
testimony dr. Redfield today and some of
the written testimony talks about the
fact that the public health system
relies on timely inaccurate data systems
but that we've under invested in them
and the crisis has quote highlighted the
need to continue efforts to modernize
the public health systems last year I
introduced a bill called the saving
lives through better data Act it was
with Senator Isakson and Senator King
and colleagues were
helpful in this we we were able to get
fifty million dollars in December in the
Appropriations deal and then another
five hundred million dollars in the
cares Act but I would urge my colleagues
to do even more because the request from
our public health communities is
significantly more sizeable I hope we
might be able to get that into the next
Co vid package doctor found cheap this
is a challenging question challenging
how to figure it out the CDC last week
said that a new group that we have to
consider at risk is pregnant women and
lactating women the night's vex
Ramez severe REMS Devere testing and
vaccine testing often doesn't include
pregnant women i think for some safety
reasons but we would want to make sure
that pregnant and lactating women have
access to treatments and access the
vaccine so how will we be trying to do
research and testing you know the the
women can safely access these treatments
or yawns that is a great question it
applies also to children so what we're
doing with the vaccine is you do a phase
one trial in normal healthy adults not
pregnant not children and you show
initial safety then when you move into
this phase two and three studies if you
get even the slightest glimpse of
efficacy and safety in that population
you go back and do a phase one in
pregnant and lactating women as well as
in children and if that is safe there
you bridge the data so that you could
use the efficacy data that you already
started to apply back to pregnant women
I see that's how you do it let me ask
you this at this point is the nation's
goal with respect to corona virus to
mitigate it or suppress it you know
vaccines right now you're talking about
vaccines so I'm just talking about what
is what is our goal are we yeah the
indicate are we trying to suppress you
know it depends on where you are there's
containment and mitigation so if you
have a level of virus that's low enough
that you can add
contained by the standard way of
identification isolation contact tracing
particularly if you make sure you link
the identification with isolation
because if you just do contact tracing
without isolation it's not going to work
when you get into a situation if I if I
could dr. pouchy cuz I don't want to go
over it I want to say just one thing
about testing real quick
Admiral girar when you were here last
you said we would have capacity to do
forty to fifty million tests a month in
September
that's about 1.3 to 1.7 million a day on
May 12th we had done about three hundred
and ten thousand yesterday we did five
hundred sixty thousand are we gonna get
to one point three to one point seven
million tests a day by September so
thank you for asking that we will
absolutely have the capacity to do that
it's depending on the need and again as
you might expect a few weeks ago the
need for testing was much less than it
is now we had a good system that it was
actually very good that we were able to
identify an increase in positivity very
early but obviously with the with the
outbreaks we're having now we need to
massively surge testing in those areas
we will have that capability across the
board yeah we'll have that and that's
assuming no pooling when we start
pooling these together three for tests
then you do the math so I'm never going
to be happy until we have more tests
that we never have to say the word tests
again but we're gonna be in reasonably
good shape given those parameters thank
you senator Kaine senator Romney Thank
You mr. chairman and thank you to each
of the panelists for the sacrifice and
the effort that you've been making over
these past several years for some past
several months as well it here as you
know because we didn't know a great deal
about this virus run on the scene in
America we ask the American people to
basically shut down their lives cut back
on flying family reunions funerals
church services restaurants bars
theaters everything got shut down
well now it's end of Jude and hopefully
we've learned something
about how this disease actually spreads
and the American people need to go back
out they're gonna go back out if they
are going back out we saw for instance
at the lake of the ozarks all these
people and we said oh my goodness this
is going to be a major problem but my
impression was because people are
outside or who knows what other reason
it wasn't to make a major problem so so
my question is this where is the risk
greatest how is it that it's spreading
is it spreading indoors is it spreading
more in restaurants and bars is it okay
to be outdoors and perhaps not socially
distance as our family reunions okay or
can you give us some guidance based on
but hopefully we know as to where the
risks are greatest I know you keep
saying social distance and mass but you
know people are getting in airplanes
they're going to restaurants where is
the risk greatest and where are we
relatively safe can you help us through
that family reunions can we get together
with family reunions outdoors is it
safer outdoors that indoors give us some
guidance can you do that to dr. Fauci
and dr. Redfield Thank You senator I
think first and foremost the most
important thing in that assessment is
knowing at the granular level what the
kinetics of transmission are in that
community as I mentioned we have 130
counties right now in the United States
where we consider them quote hot spots
we have many other areas where there's
very limited transmission so first and
foremost it's knowing the if you're in
that area of active transmission then
secondly it's it's knowing what you do
when you're in that area of active
transmission and what what precautions
one takes you know it's got to be brief
that's right all right well I think
those are the two things I will say that
there's just more and more data showing
that the use of face coverings and masks
are an effective way to prevent
transmission in in these gatherings and
I think we're just going to come back
and tell you the most important thing if
you're within a community with limited
transmission and you're wearing face
masks or there's significant
transmission you're wearing face masks
and you practice those
distancing hand-washing that's the best
thing best recommendations I can tell
you yeah in addition second outdoor
better than indoor bars really not good
really not God congregation at a bar
inside is bad news we really got to stop
that right now when you have areas that
are surging like we see right now but an
answer to your question a little bit
more granular outdoors always better
than indoor if your outdoor distance as
Bob said wear a mask if you can but you
can have some social interaction the one
point I want to make very briefly is
that we should not look at the public
health endeavors as being an obstruction
to opening up we should look at it as a
vehicle to opening up so that you don't
want to just restrict everything because
people are not going to tolerate that so
you can get outdoors you can interact
wear a mask try to avoid the clothes
congregation of people wash your hands
often but don't just make it all or none
we've got to be able to get people to
get out and enjoy themselves within the
safe guidelines that we have so make
public health work for you as opposed to
against you I much appreciate those
those responses I think it'd be
extraordinarily helpful for all of us as
we're going about our lives
if there was data that indicated where
people are getting infected were they in
a bar within a restaurant where they
outdoor outdoors at a pool I've heard
reports that virtually nobody has been
infected if they're outdoors is that
true or not true we given how long we've
been at this we've got to have more
granular data so people know where there
were there's greater risk how many
people for instance have been affected
as a result of flying on airplanes we
have to know that if we can publish that
information for the American people they
will know where they could be safe and
go back of course continuing social
business thing and wearing masks but we
need that data
finally all this hasn't won an answer
who was responsible for distributing the
vaccine what person or what agency
determines how the vaccine when it's
available will be distributed
Thank You senator this is a central
function of CDC where we really help
with vaccine distribution throughout the
nation childhood vaccine so that's so
that's so that's the CDC that's on your
shoulder Thank You mr. chairman back to
you thank you very much senator Romney
senator Hasson well thank you mr. chair
and thank you to all the witnesses for
being here and for the teams you lead I
know how hard everybody is working dr.
Redfield I want to start with a question
to you
the 43% of the deaths in this country
have been in nursing homes or long-term
care facilities in my state of New
Hampshire 80% of our deaths are
attributed to residents of nursing homes
and long-term care facilities in mid-may
the White House urged states to complete
kovat 19 testing on every nursing home
worker and resident within 14 days a
month and a half later that still has
not happened
CDC has since put out different guidance
on nursing home testing calling for a
baseline test for residents and weekly
testing for nursing home workers given
the widespread outbreaks within nursing
homes and unique risks posed to
residents what is CDC doing to ensure
that states carry out the
recommendations for nursing home testing
issued by CDC On June 13th and how many
states have met these guidelines so far
thank you senator
we are working in close contact with CMS
on on that issue as you say we're not an
enforcement agency we make
recommendations but but I'm asking and
my time is short I'm asking what what
you are doing to keep track of
compliance with guidelines 43% death
rate nationwide is huge and people are
looking to you all for granular guidance
here so what are you doing to find out
who's in compliance and who's not
I was trying to emphasize that we're
working in partnership with CMS which
has that regulatory oversight and we're
there to continue to reinforce the
guidance as you mentioned which we think
is critical and we we think we do have
to get everyone's to screened in these
nursing
and the employees every week
unfortunately we still think that we
need to keep visitors isolated from the
homes right now particularly in areas
with high jurisdictions what the
regulatory function of this is CMS but
we are really meeting with them daily to
see what more we can do to try to ensure
that there's greater compliance I thank
you for that people are looking to the
CDC for not only very clear and granular
guidelines and you've heard that all
throughout the questioning but
particularly with nursing homes and
long-term care facilities there's a lot
more work to be done and we are still
hearing that they're not getting usable
personal protective equipment all the
time either let me go to another
question and dr. Fadi I'll start with
you we've heard discussion already today
about the difference in the
effectiveness of measures taken for
instance in Europe in the United States
this is a graph that shows the disparity
between new confirmed cases per million
residents over the previous seven days
between the United States Europe Canada
and Japan the disparity is i popping
surveys suggest that mask-wearing in the
united states occurs less frequently
than in europe you and our witnesses
have been very clear on the importance
of mask wearing in public places do you
attribute the improvements in Europe to
more widespread use of masks or are
there also other specific aguh vermin
policies or individual behavioral
differences that you believe should be
incorporated into our national strategy
it certainly masks play at role but
there are a number of other multifaceted
things in each of those those very
disturbing graphs that you show one of
the things that became clear when we
shut down as a nation in reality only
about 50% of the nation's shut down with
regard to other things that were allowed
in many of the European countries 90 95
percent of all activities was shut down
so that is one of the reasons why you
saw particularly in Italy which shut
down to a much
extent than we did the cases came way
down in a shop curved downward and then
stayed so it's not only masks it's the
fact that the countries in Europe and
the other countries you have there had a
much more uniform response or a very
heterogeneous country and we had a
heterogeneous response depending whether
you are in the Northeast
southern West or what have you so
there's a number of other factors
probably some that we still don't even
understand well thank you and I I'm
gonna move on to just one other issue
and it's really just to urge dr.
Redfield and the CDC to issue additional
guidance for schools in particular on
reopening I understand that you are
continuing to do that I appreciate that
the CDC has released FAQ frequently
asked questions documents on things like
youth sports which provide more concrete
useful information for families and I'm
hoping that you'll do the same kind of
FAQ documents for parents and teachers
that directly address practical
questions and concerns about school
reopening plans simply like what happens
what should a school do specifically if
one or two positive cases come up in a
classroom or in a teacher what should
parents and teachers expect school
administrations to do so we can follow
up with that I appreciate out the chairs
and dalton's Thank You senator Hasson
senator Braun Thank You mr. chairman
I've got two sets of questions and like
for a doctoral foul she and redfield
give about a minute each to the first I
want to get the broad numbers
I think dr. Redfield you might have been
on a record that you think there's ten
times as many cases out there and I know
that's a guess I'd like to know because
if that's a case all of a sudden the
fatality rate goes from five percent
down to five ten two percent twenty
times as many cases of course two and a
half down to 0.25 what is your start
with you dr. Redfield how many cases you
think we actually have out there
and then how many vaccinations and our
herd immunity combinations as a
percentage of our total population do we
need to get to for this thing to be in
the rearview mirror so we got a few big
numbers to kind of relate the journey
ahead thank you very much senator
quickly we now know that this virus
began to really spread in the United
States and in in in in March and in
between march and the end of May you
know we've been able to do antibody
testing and that's what allowed us to
understand how many people were really
infected so that during that period it
was our best estimate about 10 to 1 so
we're probably talking over 20 million
22 million Americans have been infected
I don't want people to assume that's the
same ratio now in June and July going
forward because you think it's more than
that no I think it'll be less because
we're doing more and more testing okay
but clearly it gives us a good idea the
extent of infection was more in March
April and May not 2 million individuals
but more more closer to 20 million what
is your opinion how many individuals we
need vaccinated and are having herd
immunity before this thing goes into the
rearview mirror yeah Tony may comment on
that too it's it's really got to be over
70 percent of the population I've got to
be immune before we even see any impact
if you heard immunity dr. Fauci not yeah
I totally agree given the
transmissibility which is highly
efficient
you're gonna need soft with somewhere
between 70 and 85 percent I would say
seven-day at the lowest okay second set
of questions would be on the issue of
herd immunity because of course we've
got the we don't know how long it's
gonna take to have an effective vaccine
and I'm guessing when you're talking
about herd immunity it's got to actually
confer immunity if you get it and there
might be some uncertain get the immunity
what is the
how do we go about the approaches that
we've used to this point is herd
immunity gonna be something that you
think will march through if we take the
strategy of having a different approach
for younger people it seemed to have
lower hospitalization rates and less
significant consequences because I think
it's another thing we need to know
because I think that's already gonna be
done by each individual in a way as they
size up their own personal risk so how
much can we count on hurt immunity I can
answer quickly and then turn it to Tony
I think it's important to realize even
now we're probably looking at somewhere
between five and eight percent of the
American public has experienced this
virus so for me herd immunity as a basic
strategy you're talking about a
multi-year strategy this is why it's so
important that the alternative strategy
is a biological countermeasure in the
development of a vaccine one of the
issues that might be complicating I
don't think it's gonna be something that
is going to be any kind of a showstopper
but we've got to realize and as Senator
Paul said we have to be humble and know
there's a lot we don't know and what we
don't know is what the durability is in
other words so if you wind up getting
hurt immunity to 75 80 percent what we
need to learn and only time will teach
us this is how long this immunity last
is it a year two three four or is it
even less is it months we don't know
when we find out then that will inform
us as to whether or not if you get a
vaccine how off you need to boost it so
we have to realize we don't really know
the answer to your question in any
definitive way at least that gives some
clarity some parameters live within
Senator Hassan stressed the point of
protecting the most vulnerable because
to me the one thing it looks like we
could certainly do is to take that
highest risk group from the data we've
already got and build in essence an iron
dome around them as the one thing that
would seem to be the most important
to do where you get certain results and
I think that has to be in place as we in
the uncertainty of herd immunity and
when we get an effective vaccine
actually converge I might add just we
always think about herd immunity with
regard to natural infection and or
vaccination but when you want to talk
about protecting the vulnerable we want
to see if some of the other programs
that are more prophylactic treatment
programs like passive transfer of plasma
or monoclonal antibodies or hyper immune
globulin those are some of the things
that you can do to protect the
vulnerable until we do get an effective
vaccine thank you thank you senator
Brown senator Smith Thank You chair
Alexander ranking member Murray to see
all of you today and thank you panelists
so we need robust surveillance
occupational testing if we are going to
safely reopen our economy and our
schools our nursing homes and our group
homes to make sure that they're not a
conduit for infection and we're seeing
this a good example of this is in New
York State where employees in nursing
homes are required to get covin 19 tests
twice a week so here's the problem if
you're a worker who pays for that test
is that my employer is it my private
insurance I have insurance or do I have
to pay for it out of my pocket
so I'm thinking about that low wage
worker working in childcare or food
processing or maybe as a security worker
or janitor and you know the average cost
of a test is somewhere in the
neighborhood of 75 to 150 dollars though
there are reports of people being
charged over $6,000 to be tested
assuming you can find a test so this is
my first question last week federal
agencies posted guidance on this
question and the guidance said that
health plans are not required to cover
the full cost of tests for surveillance
or occupational reasons and the federal
testing plan which talks about the value
of surveillance testing and occupational
testing is silent on this so let me ask
you dr. pouchy do you agree that we are
going to be better able
to contain the spread of Koba 19 and
save lives if we have surveillance
testing no doubt surveillance testing is
going to be a very important part of the
program to understand not only the
current penetrance of the virus in
society but where it's going short
answer to your question is it's going to
be very important in our public health
measure and would not also the price of
these tests are the ability to pay for
these tests be a pretty significant
barrier to having that happen I think
common sense tells you that if people
cannot pay for it they're not gonna do
it and that's one of the reasons why we
got to figure out how we can do it
without having the stress of people who
can't afford it to be part of that
process and of course you know the worry
of course is that this ability to pay
for these surveillance tests for this
kind of surveillance testing that could
really tend to exacerbate underlying
inequities since a lot of front line
workers and essential workers who don't
have the privilege of working for home
or much more likely to be black and
brown and indigenous people people of
color isn't that right as in all cases
that people who are economically not
able to engage in some of the things
that benefit others they always in
general get a short end of the stick on
that and that's what we have to be
concerned about right right
well colleagues I think this is a really
important place where we have the
potential to work together sure that as
we expand surveillance testing an
Occupational look at our schools or
higher institutions of higher education
coming back and that we have the ability
to do this and that the ability to pay
for that test is in a barrier so I
appreciate it
Tara Alexander you mentioned this at the
beginning others of my colleagues have
mentioned this I think this is a place
where we could work together in a in a
constructive way
I wouldn't ask a question specifically
related to vaccines because it's been a
lot of discussion about this a lot of
discussion about how we can make sure
that people trust these vaccines that
they are
save that they work and that the
long-term consequences potential
negative side-effects we understand
those so let me just ask maybe I'll ask
you again dr. pouchy um how do we trust
the vaccine that has only had a short
number of months potentially being
tested in the human body there are a
couple of ways to overcome that first is
that you have a large number of people
in the trial the trials that we're
talking about now we're gonna have
30,000 people in the trial and maybe
even more in some of them you can get a
a considerable amount of safety data but
then there's a process you know after a
vaccine maybe would show efficacy to do
further studies following licensure
availability let dr. Han maybe comment
on that more because that becomes
something very much involved with the
FDA's authority and making sure we do
have safe vaccines so Steve let me just
um if I could maybe put a finer point in
this question for you dr. Han I mean
what if the manufacturer were to say
that they could get a vaccine to market
in January but only if they were
released from liability
what's the FDA policy on that how would
you resolve that question thank you
senator
so we would not get into the issue of
liability for an individual sponsor and
what we would do and that's why we
released the guidance this morning is we
would ensure that our normal regulatory
approach and our standards for safety
and efficacy are met so while we're all
really that's not an FDA authority that
we would that we've okay how do you
guard against running a little late go
ahead with your question but let's this
will be an easy one I mean what I'm
worried about is that there's some sort
of October surprise and that there is a
pressure put on the decision-makers here
to announce the vaccine
October of 2020 dr. Han can you just
tell us how we can have transparency so
that people can trust that that isn't
happening senator Smith a very good
question and really important and leads
to the issue of public confidence it's
why we released our guidance today we
want to be clear about what the
standards and the data that we'll need
to make a decision and what factors go
into those decision and what the
American people to hear me when I say we
will use the science and data from those
trials and we will we will ensure that
our high levels of the standards for
safety and efficacy are met
Thank You senator Smith senator Leffler
good morning thank you all for being
here sorry I can't be there in person I
wanted to ask dr. Redfield can you
outline what steps this CDC is taking to
you know look at as we prepare for
handling both the flu and kovat 19
season simultaneously this fall I know
the CDC recently developed a test that
diagnoses both covin 19 in the flu but
one of their activities is the agency
engaged in and are there any novel
approaches that you see in terms of
implementing this would love to hear
about the agency's process for
approaching the season this fall and in
your thoughts there thank you very much
senator I think it's really important to
recognize that it is going to be
difficult with flu and kovat this fall
first and foremost is to try to increase
the American public's acceptance the flu
vaccine as you know less than 50%
accepted we're working hard to begin to
reach out particularly to groups that
have been underrepresented to try to
build that confidence in vaccination
we've worked with the manufacturers to
see if they could boost the amount of
vaccine that would be available they've
now increased their commitment to almost
a hundred and eighty nine million doses
CDC bought another 7 point 1 million
doses normally we buy about 500,000 to
be able to be available to the states
and local health
for uninsured adults we've now we
increased that to 7.1 million doses
we've augmented our commitment to the
children vaccine program anticipating
that there's going to be more children
that will qualify in light of the
unemployment so those are some of the
areas that we've begun to prepare for
thank you and this question is for dr.
Hahn
you know the pandemic has has exposed
our vulnerabilities in the medical
supply chain and obviously we have a
reliance on imports from country like
China that can quickly pose a national
security risk in the face of an outbreak
of infectious disease we need to come up
with the strategy to boost our
production here both pharmaceuticals and
supplies I've introduced some
legislation titled the beat China Act to
offer incentives to companies that bring
manufacturing back to the United States
but would like to hear from you what
additional steps can policymakers take
to boost our capability to produce these
supplies and pharmaceuticals
domestically Thank You Senator Lafleur
and thank you for your leadership on
this I think one issue that we can all
agree upon is the lack of redundancy in
the supply chain and the dependency that
we've seen during the Cova 19 pandemic
has been a problem the agency's primary
focus has been on instilling redundancy
in the supply chain particularly of
pharmaceuticals by diversifying that
supply chain and really looking for
opportunities to encourage domestic
manufacturing we of course on the
regulatory side provide guidance as well
as regulations around the manufacturing
specifications to ensure quality of
pharmaceuticals and other medical
products we will continue to do that
particularly in the advanced
manufacturing space in order to
encourage domestic manufacturing we look
forward very much to working with you
and other members of Congress to see how
we can create the proper incentives to
have that redundancy and particularly to
have as much domestic manufacturing as
possible
Thank You dr. Han no further questions
I'll yield my time Thank You senator
left where senator Jones Thank You mr.
chairman thank you all for being here
today I really appreciate your testimony
your consistency over the last few
months it has got to be somewhat
discouraging to all of you as it is to
us to see these numbers I want to kind
of focus a little bit on schools as we
will start opening schools up in Alabama
in August and let me give you a little
chronology here the state of Alabama
kind of began to open up its economy
more and in May a little bit more toward
the end of May and then for Memorial Day
we saw the photographs and videos that
dr. Fauci referred to with everybody
just having a big time for Memorial Day
holiday now at the end of June we are at
our highest levels the last 14 days have
shown over 10,000 cases which is 28% of
the cases that we have seen have
occurred just in the last 14 days and at
the end of this week we have the July
4th holiday coming up and we're gonna
see a delay in hospitalizations from
right now if we do the same thing on
July 4th we're going to have a huge
problem at the end of July and early
August when we start opening schools up
our state school superintendent this
week said that it would cost about 1.8
million dollars for the average school
system to do those things necessary to
try to protect kids and the faculty but
I heard Senator Paul in his comments and
discussing a number of things to where
you would get the impression that we
could just open schools back up without
spending any of that money
so my question primarily to dr. Falchi
and dr. Redfield could you comment on
some of the statistics and some things
that you heard about children
transmitting this disease and whether or
not we need to spend some additional
monies for our schools to do things like
how have extra PPE to do things like
hiring potentially hiring additional
health officers temperature screenings
those kind of things are those going to
be necessary based on what I've heard
from senator
Paul and what happened on his charts in
other countries doctor fowey and dr.
Redfield quick I'll quickly give it a
shot and then hand it over to dr.
Redfield we don't know precisely I think
the data that was very interesting that
Senator Paul showed about school
openings and not seeing any real obvious
surge in cases is important but we don't
really know exactly what the efficiency
of spread is first of all how many
children get infected that was the
reason why in my opening statement I
mentioned the study that we're doing at
the NIH of 6,000 families looking at
children what is the rate of their
infection and how often do they infect
their families because if it's true that
the rate is down we'd know that they
don't get seriously ill with
hospitalizations when they get infected
but if the rate of infection is down and
they don't readily transmit to their
parents and family members that's going
to be very important and the decision
making process of opening schools
hopefully we're gonna find that out
reasonably soon by this study that we're
doing I'd echo what dr. Fauci said CDC
has a number of what we call household
studies going on to try to get a better
understanding of how does the virus get
into a household who brings it in what
happens with when it's in the household
how does transmission vary depending on
how the household responds in terms of
social distancing etc so there is
information that we are gathering I
think we don't know the impact that
children have yet on the transmission
cycle so I think we should just
acknowledge that the greater threat
obviously is again those children to the
vulnerable but I think one can actually
have social behavior that can prevent
that so I think that would be just to
emphasize I think it's a really
important it's been said already that we
we move forward and and work to
reopening schools in a safe way
I think of note that CDC never really
recommended closing schools it sort of
just happened
as you know we can do targeted school
closings
we have to in a particular region like
we've done for other viral diseases but
I think we really need to move forward
now and and work to how to reopen these
school safely Thank You Admiral girar
just I want to make sure you're we're
tuned in and we've talked about a little
bit are we going to be able to make sure
that we get vaccines distributed in the
most vulnerable of communities because
that seems to be where so much is
happening right now in the rural South
and are you making specific plans to
make sure that we get that into the
rural areas so thank you very much so we
all work on parts of this problem right
so the CDC actually controls the
distribution but what my office does
running the National Vaccine program
does things like the Morehouse grant
that were a cooperative agreement that
we that we announced last week that
really reaches into the rural into
Hispanic into african-american to really
have the community the people who are in
that community not only link to services
like like testing but to lay the
groundwork for vaccine acceptance
because we know that the burden of
disease is fundamentally burdened by all
on these individuals so these are the
people assuming the science works out
that we want to get vaccinated first all
right great thank you thank you mr.
chairman thank you senator Jones we know
the witnesses need to leave about one
we're going to try to respect that
senator Rosen right hold on can you hear
me yes we can morning I will try to be
as quick as I can
talking about antibodies this morning
thank you chairman Alexander making
member Murray all of our witnesses for
being here today as our communities
focus on to house safely get back to
work and school just like we're all
talking about we know we have to follow
the science and adapt to new information
to be sure that we're making timely
targeted and thoughtful decisions
protect both lives and livelihoods
so dr. Fauci the last time you were here
we talked about the
monoclonal antibody treatments and I'd
like to follow up on that conversation
if we could as if we as we've learned
more about the virus how it functions
how it's different from other
respiratory illnesses
what updates can you tell us about the
development of preventive treatments
that block the virus from attaching to
the cells that it's targeting well thank
you for the question senator you
mentioned monoclonal antibodies
monoclonal antibodies are going into
trials right now and a number of trials
sponsored by a number of groups
hopefully within a reasonable period of
time will get information as to whether
or not that's effective both in the
prevention as well as in the treatment
those antibodies are directed against a
component of the virus that is what's
called a spike protein and that protein
is the one that binds to the now
well-established receptor in your body
for the virus and that's a receptacle
ace 2 there are a number of other
studies that are not necessarily
antibody studies but studies that have a
effect on the virus itself and its
initial replication an answer to a
question that the Chairman mentions just
a bit ago is that there will be
therapies that we will be giving some
for treatment early on and others for
prophylaxis and as we hope as we get
into the fall and winter we'll have
everything from small molecule
treatments and prophylaxis to the kinds
of antibodies that you're talking about
so there's a lot of activity going on to
do that early in disease both for
prevention and for the treatment of
early disease I know that you've been
doing a lot of serology testing and that
individuals are presenting with
antibodies so out of the five types of
antibodies that people are most likely
to have which ones do most recovers
patients which ones are they show and if
one of these specific antibodies are
present
that make a difference and if the
patient can be reinfected or not or not
are the effectively immune at least for
some period of time what kind of answers
does this give us if you do have the
presence of certain antibiotics no I'm
I'd like I'd love to give you a really
precise scientifically based answer but
the fact is we don't know
standard wise when you get an acute
infection you get an IgM antibody as you
go off there in time and develop a more
chew of mature immune response it
becomes an IgG there are supple
subclasses of IgG some more protective
than others
the thing we don't know senator that we
will we will know in time but it's gonna
take time to know it is what the
relationship between the neutralizing
antibody and binding antibodies that
don't neutralize what is the
relationship between the titer and the
degree of protection and what is the
durability of protection we've seen some
puzzling things we've seen people
recover from covert infection and find
out they don't have very high levels of
anybody could it be a cell mediated
response that got them through the
illness and some other individuals have
very high levels and we don't know how
long those levels last so we're getting
there with regards to our knowledge but
it is going to take several more months
to a year to really be able to
definitively answer your question about
the role of antibodies in protection
following natural infection but building
upon that I'd like to ask this question
then we know that this virus affects
most is multi-organ and can affect your
kidneys your lungs your hearts producing
strokes all kinds of things your
digestive system your sense of smell so
I'm the science that you're talking
about the antibodies is the science of
stopping the virus from causing harm the
same regardless of which organ it
attacks and and how do we help direct
funding for the kind of research that
you're going to need to look at this
multi organ attack of this virus if you
will this is a very perplexing virus
because it's a respiratory virus and it
gets in through the respiratory tract if
the virus
days in the respiratory tract and
doesn't go systemic to involve other
organs that's good news because you
don't get very sick the other side of
the coin is your antibody response is
not as potent because when you get
systemic involvement invariably you will
have a more potent and robust immune
response so many people and probably the
people who are the asymptomatic carriers
they have a reasonable titer of virus in
their nasal pharynx but the virus
doesn't go any other place in their body
people who get multi-system disease that
get triggered by the virus those are the
ones that unfortunately get more sick
but also the ones that make a more
potent immune response thank you so much
I appreciate you all being here today
thank you senator Rosen very interesting
question senator Murray do you have
closing remarks I have one additional
question if I might draw one question
yes ma'am thank you despite some of the
limited data we do know that Cova 19 is
infecting and killing black Latino and
Native American people at a much higher
rate than white people I want to ask you
how HHS is going to adjust its response
to reduce cases and deaths and
communities of color and specifically
can you commit to redirect some of the
14 billion dollars that is in unspent
funds Congress provided to address those
disparities let me answer the two parts
of the question first as you know and
really appreciate your support we've
tried to focus our testing into high
social vulnerability communities so 70%
of our over 600 Pharmacy sites are in
high svi communities that means racial
and ethnic minorities language to
disparities socioeconomic FQHCs we've
made a major push that the federally
qualified health centers that take care
of one out of three of those in poverty
over 1300 of those are now offering
testing and of course we're super
excited about the award two more
School of Medicine last week that has a
large coalition to create a national
infrastructure to reap to reach
minorities and underserved so that's
what we're really doing and you know my
office this is what we do want to on a
daily basis even without a pandemic your
second question is I don't commit the
money so I certainly think we need
continued investment in this area
continued significant investment in this
area that the forty million dollars is a
down payment on how we could best reach
the underserved community but you're
going to have to talk to OMB about how
the money is spent oh well actually HHS
oversees that so we will ask them but I
think that's an important question I'll
keep following up and tracking that yes
ma'am um Thank You mr. chairman I
appreciate all of our witnesses taking
the time to join us today to update our
committee on the course of this pandemic
and all of our efforts to respond to it
I hope we will have continued to have an
opportunity to hear from all of you as
well as other key administration
officials about this because the
absolute worst thing we could do right
now is to pretend this crisis is over
when it is painfully obvious that is not
true the reality is that the losses in
this pandemic so far nearly unthinkable
and any further delays in our response
is really unacceptable we need to take
this president to take this crisis
seriously and lead and we need Congress
to act so I hope we can all get back to
work as soon as possible we need to
support our families or frontline
workers our businesses our schools our
communities we need to get testing where
it needs to be we need to make sure we
are making progress towards a safe
effective widely available vaccine and
we need to strengthen our ties with the
global community rather than cut them so
there's a lot left to do mr. Chairman I
look forward to working with you on this
Thank You senator Murray I know our
witnesses have a meeting they need to go
to so I'll abbreviate my remarks but one
thing I want to ask you and perhaps you
can each do it in a minute or less
I've put out a white paper in
recognition of what some of you have
said which is in between pandemics we
have found it difficult to do some of
the things we need to do to prepare for
the next pandemic so there were one or
two things that you thought we should
try to do now in order to be prepared
for the next pandemic what would those
one or two things be dr. Falchi one of
the things that I would like to see is
an appreciation on the part of our
entire nation of the importance of
responding as a nation as a whole and
not have a situation where when you have
a challenge such as we have right now we
have very disparate responses we've got
to do it in a coordinated way because we
are all in this together the other thing
I'd like to do now is to cement in our
minds as we bridge to the future the
fact that we cannot forget that what was
thought to be unimaginable turned out to
be the reality that we're facing right
now so it relates to the kind of
appreciation that outbreaks happen and
you have to deal with them in a very
aggressive proactive way dr. Redfield
Thank You mr. chairman I think the most
important thing that I could say is that
when it comes to public health threats
our nation needs to be over prepared not
under prepared and as I mentioned before
decades of underinvestment investing
investment in the core capabilities of
public health data modernization
laboratory resilience workforce mergers
response I think is fundamental we've
really been hit with this simple virus
and I think at the end of the day it's
gonna cost our nation trillions of
dollars and I think that we have a
moment in time
where I think people are attuned and I
would say now's the time to make the
necessary investment in our public
health at the local territorial tribal
state and federal level so that this
nation finally has the public health
system not only that it needs but that
it deserves
Edwige Awad of course I agree completely
with my colleagues and we're all singing
from the same hymnal here I'll say three
things number one data infrastructure is
really important when we came into this
we didn't know how many ventilators were
in use how many tests were out there
where the tests positive or negative who
is being tested I mean the complete
soup-to-nuts infrastructure that we need
to make decisions you need those data to
make decisions and to allocate resources
and now that we've built this on the fly
but we absolutely have to invest in that
secondly I would say resiliency of the
healthcare system
yes we need to attack kovat but what
happens to everything else we've seen
cancer screenings go down by 80%
childhood immunizations plummet just
about every other thing in the
healthcare system was sacrificed for our
kovat response so it's not just the
pandemic response but it's everything
else we need to do and the third thing I
would say is we continue have to focus
on health disparities if everyone was
healthier in this country if we invested
into those two hypertension diabetes
obesity all the things that could bring
the general health up you would not see
as horrible of outcomes as we have in
any pandemic so working on health
disparities that have been here for
decades is I think critical to raise our
in general health and prepare us for
whatever is gonna hit us dr. Hahn you
can have the last word
Thank You mr. chairman first of all
thank you for your leadership on your
white paper or I think that's really
important to put this conversation
forward there are two things I want to
emphasize one is the data modernization
but from an FDA perspective it's a very
manual process to number one collect
data on demand and also so the supply
chain we need a very robust system to
understand
in that we also need a robust real-world
evidence approach so that when we make
decisions in real time during an
emergency doctors do that all the time
agencies do that particularly during
public health emergencies we have the
appropriate data infrastructure to
collect real-world evidence and feedback
into our decisions and then revise those
decisions as needed critically important
for the agency and the second thing is
linked and that is to my previous
comments that Senator Lafleur asked
about we absolutely need redundancy in
the supply chain when you redundancy
manufacturing and we need to emphasize
the importance of domestic manufacturing
thank you thank you dr. Hahn well the
one thing this neeki dangerous virus has
reminded us is that there will be
another sneaky dangerous virus one day
and and we know from experience that it
may be easier to take the steps you've
just described
while our eye is on the ball rather than
between pandemics because we get
interested in other issues I'm grateful
to the witnesses for your time I think
the senators on both sides of the aisle
for really careful insightful and
courteous questioning the hearing record
will remain open for 10 days members may
submit additional information within
that time if they would like thank you
for being here the committee will stand
adjourned